thank you
thank you good evening and welcome to
this performance governance and audit
committee meeting on thursday the 9th of
june 2022
my name is councillor wendy stamp and
i'm the chairman of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and being
present in this meeting you are given
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
i ask that when invited to speak you
turn remember to turn on your microphone
and turn it off when you're finished
please reference a page and paragraph
number when referring to an agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
i would like to thank connect councillor
jeanette stiltz the previous chairman
for the work she and the committee has
done
plus councillor fleming who we are so
lucky to have her to be the vice
chairman again of this committee i'm
sure councillor stiltz will be a
valuable member of this committee as you
were as the chairman thank you again
i would also like to remind members to
treat each other and the officers with
respect
i would like to welcome the officers in
attendance tonight in the chamber we've
got richard holmes paul dodson chris
leslie sue green
stephen butcher
hannah wheatley is she here
oh she's remotely sorry um sue green and
hannah weekly's remotes with cheryl
hughes damian galea gayla stuart
jennings leander cable and of course
tara bird who we couldn't do without
kudutara and ben harrison
so moving on
have we got any apologies for absence
please tara
good evening chairman yes we're gonna
apologize from cancer
thank you
moving on members um minutes
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 24th of march
2022 found on pages 5 to 12 are approved
as a true and accurate record
i so move do i have a seconder for that
motion
council of fleming
if any member wishes to raise a matter
of accuracy they need to indicate they
wish to speak now
can we agree members by ascent
i think we'd have to speak up louder
thank you
and moving on agenda item 4 disclose
declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other peculiar
interests and non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph six to
eight inclusive of the code of conduct
for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
council fleming
i'll declare a non-pecuniary as a member
of essex county council on any matter
that might arise during the meeting
thank you
and i will also declare that i am a
member of essex county council
and
there is nothing pecuniary or
non-procuring it on tonight's agenda
okay moving on to agenda item five
members public participation
public participation has a period of ten
minutes set aside and i could advise the
committee that we have received one
written submission from david horner a
member of the public of which i will
read out this question and ask mr holmes
to reply and following that we have a
resident present in the chamber who
would like to speak mr furtick
who will read out his question in person
it is my understanding that due to the
rules of the council no participant is
allowed to distribute any display papers
plans photographs or other materials
members may have received information
prior to the meeting mr fittick has
indicated he will struggle to ask this
question in two minutes of the allocated
time but i will ask him to try
so
i'll read the first public question out
members
please could the council explain why it
is suspended all pre-application advice
and duty planner service from the 6th of
june 2022
how are members of the public now meant
to contact the planning department for
advice given that all direct phone
numbers from planning staff have been
removed
the mdc planning department are already
recognized by the wider public and other
planning professionals as failing so how
does mdc expect to recruit new staff to
an organization that is perceived to be
in dire straits and do members
acknowledge that the failure that
failure to provide a pre-application and
duty planner service
are a very public sign that mdc's
planning service needs a complete and
urgent overhaul i'm going to ask mr
holmes to
read the reply actually thank you mr
holmes thank you madam chair um whilst
there is no statutory requirement for
the local planning authority to provide
pre-application advice the lpa
acknowledges the importance of
pre-application advice in the planning
process this is something the council
has proactively looked at and expanded
in past years
unfortunately the planning service has
been carrying a number of vacancies some
time and even though there has been a
conscious effort to recruit staff the
council has struggled to provide the
high quality customer service experience
they would like to achieve and there has
to fall has needed to take a serious
consideration about prioritizing
workloads this has resulted in the
decision to put on hold the
pre-application offer to ensure the
statutory services are being provided
and that we limit the frustration for
our customers as they are aware in
advance of the predicament we find
ourselves in morgan district council
will continue to look towards recruiting
and correcting the correct team members
alongside a number of other ideas and
options to ensure the planning team are
able to reintroduce pre-application
advice opportunity however it is worth
noting the issue is not restricted just
to warden district council and other
authorities have had to make similar
decisions and in some cases made
decisions i considered perhaps even more
extreme
notwithstanding the above the entire
council has had a brutal branch
restructure when it's live in november
2019 one of the key outcomes of this
restructure was to encourage a channel
shift in customer interaction members
agree to a new direction for customer
service that does heavily rely um on i.t
and limits customer interaction with
specialists in the council and therefore
the customer experience would be very
different before the transformation the
council recognizes the need to set out
the position clearly for its customers
and will improve the messaging for
greater clarity thank you
thank you mr holmes um right mr pittuck
would you like to come forward and take
a seat
um and it's usually council fluke or
council lag and i'll help you you need
to put on the microphone and you wait
for the two two minutes has
magically appeared on the clock so as
soon as you start speaking the two
minutes um
we'll start okay just just take your
time breathe you'll be fine glad you're
introduction first things 10 o'clock
sorry
okay you
turn your microphone on
dear madam chair counseling officers
i'm referring to corporate performance
paid q for appendix one
question one is the 75 percent trigger
why is it not prudent to conduct a
speedy partial review i'll quote from
the inspector if strategic allocations
deliver less than 75
it commits the council to a partial
review it will allocate additional
housing sites if necessary and will
ensure sufficient infrastructure
capacity is available
i have a second question
s2d mobile world is forecast at circa
four percent build out
well below benchmark studies of nine to
twelve percent
i dropped from a plan 126 to 50 per year
is best part of a loss of a year's land
supplier
is there not a possibility that the
numbers are being unduly micromanaged
creating reported instability
third question the inspector commented
that the council had put forward
modifications that make it clear
significant infrastructure constraints
exist which will strictly limit the
capacity for development
and explicitly state that the council
will resist proposals unless they could
be accommodated without prejudicing or
delaying planned infrastructure
improvements
so is there a risk that required
infrastructure will be compromised due
to s2d s106 contributions being delayed
or hostile developments in the wrong
location whilst the full ldp review has
been undertaken
the fourth question the report states
that land supply increased from 3.26 to
3.37
3.26 has been accepted as incorrect it
should have been 3.78 my belief that
there's another 90 that was excluded
from the calculation bringing up the
4.07
hence it has not increased from 3.26 it
declined from 4.07 or 3.78
i would like to end by quoting the south
minster parent
whose child has been told to attend
william to fellow school due to lack of
infrastructure i.e school places
he said i live local
my son should go local i've paid into
this village for the last year to end up
with this
thank you very much for your time thank
you mr fitz
um
mr johnson would you like to
attempt to answer those questions or do
you want to give a
little guide to all members and mr
pintock i'm sure you could answer one or
two of them maybe
um i will answer
by written response as i didn't have a
chance to review all of those questions
prior to the
the meeting um
but certainly the the points made around
the the five-year housing land supply
which i think you were still talking
about towards towards the end
the the five-year housing land supply is
3.66
years um and that will be our published
figure
um there's also a report going to our
overview and scrutiny committee
um that will outline both the
methodology the reasons for why that
figure is as it is and we'll also
demonstrate the
how the housing trajectory was set and
how it's been deviated from in the
delivery so all of that information will
be available um through that route
i think some of the other questions that
you asked were quite detailed and i
would like to revert to a written
response to those chairmen thank you
thank you okay thank you you can stay if
you want to watch the rest of the
meeting you're more than welcome
okay
right members moving on agenda item
number six notice of motion
sorry oh sorry sorry counselor plucker
thank you chairman um um welcome to the
hot seat point of order um which point
of order pump forward
i'm just a little bit concerned
because i think mr horner was told that
he had to come here this evening by
committee services
and then he was told that you were going
to be kind enough to ask his question
um the agenda says that you have to
complete the online thought i i think
it'd be helpful for everybody perhaps if
someone could have a look at this rule
because
um you know if mr fittick had actually
submitted his question in advance he
would got an answer tonight in the same
way as mr horner had so i i really do
think we need to understand whether or
not a member of the public really does
have to come here to ask a question
or whether or not they can just submit a
written question because it's not clear
anywhere in the rules
well we can look at it uh councillor
fluker but i made the decision to read
the question out um which is obviously
the chairman's right to do uh and mr
fitz if he didn't want to attend i'm
sure he could have emailed one of us and
said that he would either put the
written question in but yes we will we
will look at that and if we need to
change anything we will do it um but
it's quite clear that the constitution
quite clear about the online to fill in
the form firstly
so uh noted
uh gender item six notice of motion
um
notice of motion the council
constitution and the scheme of
delegation i'll just going to read out
the purpose of this report members the
purpose of the report of this report is
to provide background information and
advice to enable the committee to
consider the implications of notice of
motion recently received and considered
by the council and report back to the
council
now what i'm going to do the way i'm
going to handle this is i'm going to
hand over to councillor lagan because
it's his motion and council legend has
five minutes to actually speak on this
and then we'll follow it with the any
recommendations that's a lag and please
thank you thank you madam chair um
even members giving officers um as many
people know um the intention behind the
motion um is to look at change and to
look at more openness and member
involvement but after careful
consideration um i request that i
withdraw the motion from tonight's
agenda uh we don't debate it and i also
request that we withdraw the motion from
full council as a recommendation
thank you madam chair
okay i do i just do i
do i need a second for that i don't
think i do i think i can just that can
just be withdrawn it goes to full
capsule
okay thank you i'll get a second just in
case thank you cancer thompson but i
think it just goes to full council
because it was
it was proved and recommended to come
down to this committee so i think just
to cover all bases because i'm a little
bit unsure unless tara do you know
on mr jennings
and one second mr jenny's coming in
report back to council of what the
intention was as a result of council
11's submission to you okay that's fine
i'm quite happy with that cancer fluker
mr jennings took the words out my mouth
and we've both spent a lot of time
together in the past looking at the
constitution so i see it the same way
fantastic moving on agenda item seven
this is yours councillor fluker isn't it
notice of motion cancel constitution and
questions to the leader the purpose of
this report members
is
to enable the compete committee to
consider and report to the council on
the proposed change to the constitution
um i've been informed there's no
secondary required because it's already
been seconded and recommended from full
council so councillor fluka i know how
you like to speak first and you have
five minutes please
and then i will put the recommendation
if if so
yeah thank you chairman um i think i can
come back afterwards as well and
firstly members are um i refer the
members to uh the report mr jennings and
ask them to note that it does not
actually counter the proposal for
allocating 15 minutes to the asking of
questions
and refers to the main change paragraph
3.2 would be for the leader to provide a
written response if they are unable to
answer the question at the time
so it doesn't really
speak
to
the allocation of 15 minutes to the
asking of questions
also chairman there's the question of
beyond 10 pm
i mean
if one looks at um
part four the rules procedure and in
particular um
rule one six i think it is um it's not
relevant because within that
rule it says quite clearly that meetings
can know it's a bit bully but it
actually says that meetings could only
go on for two and a half or three hours
so that's actually sovereign to anything
in there so chairman i tabled this
motion in the spirit of public interest
openness and transparency although the
counsellor had although the council has
a conservative administration no one
group or par political party has an
overall majority for that reason
uh it's imperative that all members
especially those that are not members of
the conservative administration are
given the opportunity to ask questions
of the leader of the council
moving forward and beyond this evening
chairman the right to do so will become
even more relevant towards the end of
this administration and particularly so
in the build-up of the district council
elections in may 23.
part four the procedure rules
rule 1.3 m allocates a total of 15
minutes for both questions and answers
from the leader to be heard
in the past issues have risen where both
questions and answers have been so
protracted that the 15 minutes allocated
under current rules
has been reached in advance to some
members
being able to put the questions
um given the overall challenges that the
the council now faces
uh it's certain that there is going to
be a number of questions wanted but put
put by members to the leaders we will
increase
i mean you know we've got issues with
local development plan there's issues
with budget there's issues all over the
place at the moment and i'm sure that
members representing the residents will
want to put questions and there's going
to be more and more questions so
chairman the the motion proposed to
change 1.3
m to a maximum of 15 minutes for the
asking of questions this would be in
addition to the time taken to answer
questions
if if members acted succinctly then such
a change would allow those members to
wishing to ask question the time to do
so and as a result the democratic post
process behind this motion would be
satisfied chairman you'll remember that
at a meeting of malden football club i
think councillor helm actually made a
proposal along these lines
um
and roundly speaking
the the opposition groups which
basically the the the uh the the the
tory group um
supported the proposal that we we did
this and others
the majority didn't so i'm hoping this
evening chairman that there's going to
be a coming together of mines in the
best interests of everybody to allow
this happen
so i hope all members will now recognize
the importance of being able to ask
questions of the leader for the benefit
of residents and businesses and that in
the best interest of openness
transparency they support the motion as
table chairman thank you
right members to be able to debate it
anybody wish to say anything but to be
able to debate it the recommendation is
that the committee considers the
proposed change to the constitution and
recommends accordingly to the council
members
right i don't think they want to speak
counselor channel so um i'll i'll let
you speak council chinese but you've
asked me if you could speak first speak
at this committee and of course you can
um
yes i will chairman uh
say for those uh sort of jeers from the
right there
um actually madam chairman i feel
there's nothing wrong with the president
constitution in fact i'm glad council
lucas made something quite clear there
that he's saying the leader should be
questioned for 15 minutes without the
responses being given that's the time
just for the question that's what i
heard counselor luca say now mr jennings
has looked at this and he's saying the
time should be 15 minutes as it's always
been the asking of questions and
responding i'm sure i'm quite correct in
that
we've had this constitutional rule
phrase it's got nothing to do with
transparency and democracy and at the
last meeting actually i was subjected to
a quite prolonged over 15 minutes of
questions and answers in fact i've timed
them all and in fact they were
significant and in fact what didn't
happen was there was no
consultation with the chairman with the
leader to extend that
that never happened at all in fact some
other things brought in which changed
that and i do recall actually when i was
in the chair um i'm sadly when
councillor boy stood down and i think it
was the sixth of august meeting which i
remember now and there were questions
put to the leader at that time and in
fact um that perhaps the question wasn't
answered in the way a member wanted but
it was nonetheless the leaders answer
and i had to make that point quite clear
more than once remember that the leader
that was the answer of the leader now
one could argue it hadn't been answered
however it's the prerogative of the
leader in a way what this is about and
it's nothing to do with we can have more
and more questions i think that might be
a leading to that and in fact i would
say two years ago was a far more torrid
time when perhaps a lot more questions
could have come forward and a lot of
challenges certainly within the last um
two years three years i would hasten to
add and i won't go into the reasons what
they may be um but yes we are going on
with the business but i think what has
been held in the constitution previously
is sound it does answer the openness and
transparency and in fact during that
question time when there was a question
and it was councillor stilts actually
asked it regarding the pontoon and i
could give so much information i
actually offered and said that i would
give um a right a
full answer in writing and circulate to
all members and i believe that should be
the leader's prerogative nothing to do
with not valuing democracy and
transparency but i think what councilor
fluke is asked to hear is actually he's
trying to bring in um not having any
discussion with the leader of extending
the time for 15 minutes because he's
making it clear it will be above 15
minutes because he's saying the 15
minutes should just be for the
questioning only not the answering
um involved thank you
thank you councillor chana does any of
the members before councilman fluke wish
to come in
um
cancer thompson
um thank you chairman well council
channel said everything i was even
contemplating saying so i won't keep
anyone for long
um i think
i believe the constitution is fine as it
is it's worked so far i think as long as
the leadering does in fact answer the
question as opposed to refuse to answer
a question which has happened i think
you know it's something it should be up
to the leader to
deal with these matters we've always
done 15 minutes questions can be asked
and answered
it is
if people want to get a lot of questions
in as councillor fluke rather implied
it's up to the members to be fairly
succinct about it
and no i'm afraid i can't support this
motion as it is no sorry
thank you
um
councillor helm you haven't asked to
speak to me you didn't ask me if you
could speak before the meeting
sorry
anybody else any other member i i i
it doesn't matter that it was second did
councillor flicker second did it full
council this is a total different
committee meeting it's a recommendation
that came from bull cats or to this
committee if council of helm would have
asked me prior to the meeting to speak i
would have as he has always done we
there's processes that needs to be
followed council of luca
please don't stare me out counseling
it's not going to make me uncomfortable
believe me
well i've got two pairs if you'd like to
borrow one that's fine right
members
anybody else wish to speak
thank you cancer jeff i
you know
i'm sure that councilman wasn't going to
say anything innocuous i'm a bit
surprised you stopped him speaking but i
think what he was going to say was both
the leader and the deputy leader at a
previous meeting actually voted in favor
this motion when they were in opposition
so there's nothing more open and
transparent for that for anyone that's
listening to this tape um but chairman
the leader talks about democracy and
transparency in a slightly different way
to me but chandler this is all to do
with the opportunity for members to put
questions to the leader at the moment
they are hogtied by the 15-minute rule
and i think that
residents who come to members who aren't
happy with the particular issue that
want the question asked need to make
sure that those questions are asked and
at the moment the way this system works
it's failed because people spend too
long asking questions
and too long answering them and it just
uses up all the time you know to me
chairman to vote for this
i think it's the right thing to do it
allows everybody in the council to ask
questions potentially 30 people could
answer the question i doubt whether they
would but most people for questions the
minute they're being precluded
the answers can roll on and on and on
and we all know what filibusting is and
we've all seen it done before
so
my motion is on the table i believe
members it's a it's a motion for
democracy and i think that
anybody that votes against it chairman
particularly the leader and the deputy
leader really have to account for the
public why they won't want to be
scrutinized over 15 minutes thank you
chairman
thank you well members you can put them
out
councillor thompson
and of course you can you can come back
i was referred to by
well
you just wait for a minute till they
open the windows
just give us a moment please of course
chairman thank you
councillor thompson is going to speak
more than happy to give way to the
leader i'm sure you'll allow us to have
i'd like to stay
with you absolutely fine thank you um i
have to say um
i do resent that comment um the 15
minutes could cover everything 30
minutes seems to be good enough for
parliament the house of commons which
does seem to have more and bigger issues
there are 650 of them after all who
could be there
um
it would help if cash questions were
synced and
not that i'm
including council of fluker in this but
if they weren't planted in advance to
make everything take as long as possible
that would help
that's my view i'm sure i don't have to
explain it to you and i'll explain it to
anyone else who wants it to be explained
after the meeting thank you thank you
councillor thompson um final time leader
um thank you uh madam chairman i stand
by what i said i actually do think
there's another part on the agenda
where questions can be put with notice
actually and that's the way that
actually questioning can be done and it
will cut down the time because actually
in the meetings and the length of
meetings i can see meetings having to go
past 10 o'clock which is also i know
council of lucas made reference to that
can be done actually i think the
chairman's can have the prerogative to
actually if they feel the business needs
to continue rather than adjourning it
asking the committee whether they want
to go on i maintain the constitution has
always been fine as it is always worked
and i don't and as i say i believe
within the last three years two years
there's been far more areas of
more perhaps
public and transparency interest and as
um
councillor mrs thompson referred to i
can recall questions not being answered
by um leader and brackets leaders and at
that time i did actually say that was
the leader's answer i know it wasn't i
knew it was frowned on by that member
but that was the ruling of the
constitution simon should remain madame
chairman that's why i think thank you
council fuku i'll let them come back i
know i shouldn't normally and i won't be
this lenient would you like to have the
final say on this i'll have you said all
you wanted chairman i've i've followed
the walls you know i was given the
opportunity to summarize which is and in
theory the move in the motion is the
last person that spoke
but i noticed that you you didn't go
that way and it's your prerogative so no
i don't it's my prerogative to give you
the chance to speak again counselor no
it will not come to the walls you'd have
to use rule 32 to do that so yeah i i'm
going to be difficult at every every
minute of every opportunity i've given
you the option to speak if you don't
want to speak then kindly just say thank
you madam chair we'll go to the motion
right thank you very much madam chairman
i was merely referring to the walls
which this council has to abide to i'm
not being difficult i'm just saying as
it is as the rules are so put the motion
thank you
can i have a recorded vote
do you have a second different recorded
vote
there is
oh okay so
thank you
tara we're going to have a recorded vote
on the motion
the recommendation of the motion is that
that considers the proposed change the
constitution and recommends accordingly
to the
members thought against stanley please
if you council
want to call your name out and this is
to accept the motion that's put by
chancellor peter uh starting with
councillor edwards please
okay
tara he's not present actually
against
assistant
i will abstain
against
that was against tara if you didn't hear
that
she didn't have a microphone on sorry do
you have my mic
okay tara is that everybody
[Music]
thank you very much
thank you thank you members
moving on to agenda item number
seven no we're on eight aren't we
review of the corporate performance
thank you thank you
88
review of corporate performance quarter
four to consider the report
from the director of strategy which is
um
mr dodson so the purpose of the report
members and i'll read this out first
before we go any further the corporate
performance framework requires this
committee to undertake a quarterly
review of the thematic strategies
performances
as assured that performance is being
managed effectively to achieve the
corporate outcomes as set out in the
council's corporate plan 2021 to 2023
little appendix one to this report
provides an overview of performance as
to the end of quarter four january 22 to
march 22
illustrating that 2021 to 2022 end of
year
eoy position online versions are
available
appendices 2 3 and 4 detail the full
list of key performance indicators for
each strategy with highlighted changes
in readiness for the 2022 to 23
performance monitoring as demonstrated
as the recent member workshop so on
pages 25 to
21-56 i'm now going to ask is it mr
dodson are you doing this one mr dudson
no thank you chairman i'll defer to mrs
hughes um
mr hughes would you like to take this
one and present the report to council
please
thank you so this report is the board of
water covering january into march 22 and
gives an end-of-year position of
performance against the corporate plan
objectives
section 3.2 of the covering report shows
a summary level of performance against
the three strategic themes
for place there is one outcome at risk
which is delivering the housing the
district needs mainly due to the five
year housing land supply in prosperity
there are two outcomes at risk which are
enabling future economic investments and
new jobs and enhancing and promoting the
district's visitor economy
both of these are due to
resource diversion come this and work is
ongoing to address these
in community there are no outcomes at
risk
section 3.3 of the covering report then
shows the more granular kpis that
contribute to those outcomes and
highlights the poor that have been
marked at risk
the attached appendix which starts at
page 26 of your agenda pack gives the
full detail and breakdown of the
performance information
the format of the appendix has been
revised following committee feedback and
in readiness for our 2223 reporting
it now incorporates a summary page to
show high-level delivery and each
outcome has its own designated page or
pages with all of the commentary and
data measures that contribute to the
scoring
as highlighted in recommendation little
pre appendix 2 starting at page 49 of
your agenda pack also gives information
about which measures will be kept
revised or added for the
2223 corporate performance reporting
members are invited to review the
information set out and confirm their
assurance that corporate performance is
being managed effectively thank you
thank you miss hughes
right the recommendation members are
that members review the information as
set out in this report and appendix one
with priority focus given to the
strategic outcome level performance
little two that members confirm that
they are assured through this review
that corporate performance is being
managed effectively and little three
that members note that the kpis that are
will be monitored for 22 23 can i have
iso proposed from the chair can i have a
second
councillor fleming thank you members
i'll open it up for debate
thank you councillor hell
um councillor stealth
thank you thank you madam chair um just
a few questions
um i think last time at the meeting we
actually asked with the on page 27 with
the uh flight tip clearance actually
whether we got any of that money back
um
that it cost us to
for the flyer tipping
so that was one question the other one
was pay on still on page 28 and it was
prom park and riverside park
satisfaction why have they dropped so
suddenly
you know we've gone from 63 for the prom
park down to 56 and on the riverside
park from forty percent down to twenty
percent
customer satisfaction
why is there such a big drop in that
when we're saying that everything's on
track and it's fine
thank you council still miss hughes
would you like to answer that one for us
please or is it yeah misuse yeah i can
answer the one around the drop in the
satisfaction numbers and that's based on
the annual uh resident survey feedback
and we did have less responses this time
so um
you know we do need to apply a bit of
caution when looking at the data in the
uh
more of a way if one or two people are
less happy um but that being said that
those are the um satisfaction figures
that were given in the resident of
business survey
that's the change so it's an annual
measure and that's the percentage that
said that they were satisfied this time
around
and
we haven't got a
set kpi attached to that
which is why it's not
well we've got to improve on
satisfaction rates
but it's not necessarily triggering
triggering
a threat because of the wider work
that's going on on that
particular outcome
uh in terms of flight ticket now i think
ric should home is probably a better
place to answer
thank you thank you um apologies if we
missed that particular point you wanted
to raise so we obviously do pursue um uh
fly tips and obviously investigate fly
tips wherever possible and where we can
actually attribute the uh the tipping to
an individual we will pursue um to help
members what i'll do is i'll get some
statistics on that and circulate that to
the community so we can see how
successful or not we've been
thank you council since council of luca
thank you joan i just wanted to drill
into something that council still said i
mean on page 28 these these um
satisfaction surveys um and apologies if
i missed it and how many people
were were actually polled for this do we
do we know if it was 500 or 5 or how
many will actually return their surveys
uh mrs could you answer how many people
return the surveys please do you have
that information off the top of my head
it was recently circulated but not off
the top of my head i will get that
answer back to the committee i think
it's a couple of hundreds and it's we
had less response this year than the
year before
um which we expect it's due to covered
as well but i will get the details
around the committee yeah i think i
think it is important that we get the
drill down data i think the last
committee meeting i attended when
councillor stiltz was there and i think
cancer food was asking the questions we
can answer the voice um it is important
that when we ask for the data it does
try and come it's not a criticism but if
you could get that to all members but
i'd be grateful that's the fluke
chairman i think it'd be quite simple if
we just put on each of these um graphs
what the sample number is so if we've
got 200 responses we can understand but
i mean really julie councillor stilts
and i just enjoyed a very great moment
there where we look completely bemused
chairman and i think that would be
helpful
is that all right with you ms hughes
yeah we can do that thank you thank you
uh any other member
um
counselor
now go on counselor hall i've called you
first i think oh thank you page 55
number 10 about mental health um i i'm
i've got an experience of it a lot
happening um i can't see people are
waiting two years to get counselling at
the moment um
because the covid is sort of caused a
big problem is anything more can be done
about that do you know
um who would like to answer that it's
not really
mr dodson are you coming in yes thank
you chairman
um yes the
some of those
there are delays in some of that that
area of work exactly as you say because
of covid
the
the one modern district group that we've
just set up is to work closely with the
the health service and to make sure that
we're addressing those mental health is
a key priority
within the um the strategy for the
well both the the ccg that's outgoing
and and the incoming
integrated care board so we will be
pursuing that that through them and i
totally agree it's something that that's
really important given the the
statistics as well that are around
mental health not just in this district
but but across the whole county of essex
so we've got a high suicide rate in our
area at the moment
thank you councillor hall i'm cancer
stilts
thank you madam chair i do actually have
quite a few questions oh sorry thank you
are you opening your privacy
uh page 37 can you explain why the
more visit malden district web traffic
has dropped quite dramatically
um when we've had the channel shift and
so many people are going on the website
very good question who's that who's
going to answer that i think it's that
is that you misuse or would that be yeah
so the um quarterly changes in that
chart are largely seasonal changes i i
assume you're talking about the ph of
the issues different
traffic yeah so the um
the pizza troughs are largely seasonal
changes
council stilts another one yeah there's
another one
can you put your microphone on please
cancer still thank you page 38
we say we attract a large footfall from
the
motor show and the steam fair as it has
been indicated both of these are not
returning what are we going to do to
read get business in for those
two big events
i don't know who can actually answer
that i don't think
mr holmes
thank you chairman um yes uh we have had
the larger events in the past which um
have obviously brought this to the
economy and brought attractions to the
town itself uh steam fair as you say is
now out of our control effectively
they're moving into a different
operating model um stopping what they're
doing effectively and the car show
itself was done in partnership with a
club
and a charity um and unfortunately they
were unable to support it to the level
that we would uh we could actually step
up and and take the strike the slack in
fact and then take over from them so
that that meant we couldn't actually run
that show um however i know mr butch is
looking at a number of commercial
opportunities and that does include
concessions and events on prun park so i
think you know our bigger plan is to
look at other attractions and look at
other um possible options for us to take
new events forward
thank you i'm just going to stay with
cancer stilts and i've got councillor
edwards and councillor hall okay um page
45
c 20
12 it's the percentage of mdc customer
facing staff who have received make
every um cat every contact account
training
we got quite a lot a big drop on that we
were on target and now we're only 63
percent of our
are people doing the training
who's who's going to answer that one oh
thank you thank you
thank you members um that's due to the
turnover in in our customer facing staff
so um we have a num we have had a
quite a sizable turnover in the last 12
months of our staff so there is a
program of work that we will be
reintroducing and we have got a number
of staff that will be undertaking that
training
any more
the other one's page 55 but i don't
think we've come on to that one yet i
can always come back to you counselor
hall
um just like to say um we're the
churches together holding in burma
crouch elm farm uh on the 10th of july
uh wheels and paws um attraction that if
it's anything to go by from last year
and we had many people there so we hope
you can all come to that that was a
cheap advertising uh thing for burning
man crouch i'll let that go because i'm
a burnout crash member at cancer
redwoods
uh yes thank you
i just got a question on the events
um the recent cancellation of
monday market i think
uh it was that due to a paperwork a
response
from the hiris
was that mr holmes i think that one
thank you um i will put it there's a
communications issue between the the
operator and the council and we were
looking for a certain level of
information um i think there was uh
probably i would say communications
broke down between the two parties and
it got to a point where actually it's
very close to the government and the
operator wasn't able to provide that
level of assurance and we've
subsequently spoken to the operator and
to ensure that we do have that level of
communication and obviously ready for
the august bank holiday market coming up
risk assessments
yes general documentation basically
around risk assessments um and uh
things such as food hygiene certificates
and things like that so i think all of
it was possible but i think the time
scales were um but challenging and i
think there was a different view as to
the level of information required
thank you any any more council
just sort of developing on what council
edward said yeah and a lot of people
were disappointed i i know um
you know i would have thought moving
forward and mr holmes hasn't mentioned
it but i'm sure he's done it but you
know we really need to have a template
right at the beginning when somebody
comes to us and says right this is what
i want to do you know the first thing
that should be on there really is public
liability risk assessments method
statements health and safety then all
your food hygiene certificates and then
saying how we're going to deal with it
so if we have something in place right
at the beginning then anybody that comes
to us is under no illusion what is
required rather than waiting until the
last moment and we can't tick the boxes
so i i do hope and i fear the way your
thumb is hovering you're about to
reassure me mr holmes yes i'm sure you
are about to reassure councillor uh
you're exactly right that's what uh the
council does require but what the issue
was between asking that question covid
and we're also dealing with an operator
who's been operating for a number of
years with the council that gap and then
restarting i think created a problem so
when we came back to reaffirm the
position it was very late in the day to
do that but what i would say is that um
the the bank holiday market concession
and will be renewed at the end of this
year it will be picking up our standard
terms and conditions but set out exactly
all those points you said before we even
sort of enter into those agreements as
assurances around what will be provided
so it's a it's a tighter process um
going forward i would say that probably
give you that level of reassurance
thank you anybody else members
no well we have a proposal in a second
can we agree by ascent
thank you
gender item nine
purpose of this report this is a risk
the review of the corporate risk quarter
four
the risk management policy requires this
committee to undertake a quarterly
review of the corporate risk register
and assurance that the corporate risks
are being managed effectively obviously
in appendix one i'm sure everybody's
read these appendixes but hopefully at
the next meetings i won't have to read
so much out
it's attached to the report for this
purpose
so i'm going before i put the
recommendation forward i'm going to hand
over to is it uh
mr dodson
oh is it miss hughes again oh sorry miss
hughes you're you're working very hard
today i put mr dodson's name for them
all but it's obviously you thank you
okay so this report is the fourth
quarter covering january into march 2022
for the corporate risk register
um appendix one is found on pages 59 to
66 of your agenda pack and kiss the
whole table of the corporate risk
register as at the end of march 22.
section
3.2.1 of the covering report shows that
no risks have changed direction since
4-3
but section
3.2.2 highlights a new risk that has
been added for this quarter which is
risk 32 failure to manage the
operational impact of the cost of living
crisis
members are asked to review the risk
register update and confirm assurance
through this update that corporate risk
is being monitored effectively thanks
um thank you
the recommendations members are little
one that members review the corporate
risk register in appendix one and
provide comment and feedback for
consideration little two that members
are assured through this review that
corporate risk and is being managed
effectively and little three that
members challenge risk where the
committee feels that the council's
corporate goals may not be achieved um
can i i will propose that from the chair
do i have a secondary
council fleming thank you members i'll
open it up would anybody like to speak
on this corporate risk
oh
i'll ask members first if that's all
right with you council lagging i know
you've asked if you could speak but any
members wish to come in first
council again
thank you madam chair thank you members
um
obviously i'm not on the committee so i
don't scrutinize the documents as
detailed as other members do but one of
the areas of concern that that's been
spiking at me for the last few weeks
is risk seven now our failure to
maintain a five-year housing land supply
and again um this is my comments are
about process not about people
um with mr fittick tonight coming in and
raising that the he sees a different
calculus in the five years how housing
land supply
to what's actually being published
causes me a degree of concern
um i also think that we're we're
chomping along with the five-year with
the
ldp
as we are and there may be some
significant legislative changes coming
up very shortly that
michael govers has tabled with regarding
that if we've got a sound plan we may
not need to have a five-year housing
land supply
so it's really to share with members my
concern that um i think it's it may be
time for us to sort of maybe have a
pause
uh and to get some more detailed
information and to see how
um scrutinizing the current review of
the ldp uh and and how that goes forward
and the impacts that it could have if
things significantly change because of
mr gove's potential recommendations uh
it can also you know i'm talking from a
naive perspective here but it could also
be a point that it could save us a
significant sum of money i know council
have approved it but i feel that because
of the magnitude of the risk that this
carries
those points should be considered
um and i intend to bring a paper uh put
a motion to whatever committee that i
need to put it through uh with lots of
detail um to to raise those concerns
because i think this is something that
if we get wrong
going forward it will be catastrophic
for the district
so that's just the point madam chair
again it's about process not people and
thank you for letting me speak thank you
councillor um mr dodson do you want to
come back on anything like that
yes i mean we've we've had a
thank you chairman we've we've had a
discussion i think in council previously
and certainly in the working group
around the the ldp and the
issues
with the review the issues and the the
relative risks of progressing at pace or
waiting for for legislative um changes
that that may or may not come and you
know even even in this program that
we've been working on with the the ldp
the legislative changes that have been
proposed have have changed um at least
twice
um
and whilst the bill's on its way through
um
through parliament now
um there's no
certainty still at the moment of the the
changes that are coming
um so it is important that we we
continue on with the work
you know there are a number of
authorities who paused their plans and
who were challenged by government
because they'd done that
and that there were also some which have
withdrawn plans
um
the the most effective way
of having a strong plan
planned housing delivery within a
district is to have an up-to-date ldp
so the overall risk
to me that is the lowest is to progress
and to ensure that the work can inform
any change can can still continue and be
informed by any changes to legislation
that come alongside it and at the moment
that view hasn't changed from when it
was previously discussed um as i say i
think it was a council or the working
group but but there's certainly been
discussion around that but obviously as
further certainty comes around the
legislation and the implications of it
it's something that officers will take
into account
you can come back
yeah and i appreciate that you know i'm
still not i sort of understand that it's
it's for me it's it's all of those
things but it's also
having the the time maybe to to have i
wouldn't get rid of the plan yeah i
wouldn't sit here council wouldn't
accept it i could really understand that
but i also think because there's so many
questions and variables that are coming
into
to the plan review now um i've i feel
with the the information that i've
started to gather from external from
other agencies etc that you know you you
could
potentially review the plan but not at
the level that we're doing but at a
lower level um it's just more of an
option on it before the certainty comes
in because we don't know where about
significant infrastructure projects are
going to go ahead down in bradwell
there's a lot of anomalies that we we
just don't know
so
from my perspective from and from a
member's perspective i still think we
should circulate the information and i'm
not going to do it covertly
and if members feel that it's worth
taking further then we will do that if
members feel it's not then then we're
not it's not a criticism and i
understand that you need to carry on
with it at the moment so
lots to do do you do you don't need to
come back on that
thank you
anybody else council fleming please
thank you chair through you i just
wanted to ask mr dodson um when he was
talking about
legislative changes um
were you
referring to the infrastructure levy i
just wondered if we'd put in some
thought and preparation as to how that
would play itself out thank you
there isn't the clarity within the bill
at the moment to to prepare fully i mean
there are there are proposals around the
um
the changes to the infrastructure levy
um from section 106 there's also changes
around proposals to have street votes
on on whether people have extensions
built
um
those are ideas within the bill at the
moment and i think
we're we're still awaiting the clarity
around them and there's still no clarity
where they're all all measures within
that bill
will come forward
um in the fullness of time so
we're monitoring
and um along with
you know planners across the country
looking further the intelligence on
exactly what that's going to look like
and as soon as we know we'll um
make the arrangements and and
changes
and and address that within the work
we're doing but at the moment it's
evidence-based gathering which isn't
hugely affected
by the those changes
thank you um council stills
thank you madam chair i did actually
have a question on page 55 but we've
done that so i'll move on would you like
to put it in writing and we'll get it
yes i'll put it in writing to the
committee and then we can get the
answers the question i've got is on page
60 um r8 failure to meet affordable
housing needs this risk is unchanged
from the other times
why are we not doing anything or are we
doing anything positively to bring this
risk down so that's one question
right should we do it one at a time and
then it's
who would like to take that
mr dodson's going to answer that not mr
gohan
um yes our
affordable housing delivery has been
reasonably good over the last few years
um and we're also continuing to
monitor
the delivery and make sure that that's
happening we're also where we've
you you'll recall a paper came around
commuted sums and ensuring that when
housing couldn't be delivered that we
were taking um commuted sums um and
you'll also be aware of the the projects
that are being put forward through the
commercial team to look at how we as a
council can enable further sites to be
available for affordable homes delivery
so there's considerable activity um
going on there
but there's still a risk attached with
it until it comes to fruition so that
that's why it's unchanged but it's it's
not that there isn't a lot of activity
going on to to ensure that we achieve
those targets
thank you i'm going to stick with
councillor stiltsville and i'll come
back to to you consistent
well thank you madam chair the other one
i'm still on page 60 is r15 which is the
failure to plan and deliver balanced
budgets over the medium term this is at
risk
and it's unchanged what are we doing to
bring this back down
yeah okay so in terms of that side of it
um we've obviously had the uh all member
uh briefing which i think outlined a
number of the activities
going on around that and that was
circulated to all members with the q a
responses around that which list
actually the sustainable actions that
are going in um i spoke at i think
probably snr committee about the
processes which are in place within the
council around the budget monitoring
side of it where we look at our budgets
we look at our assumptions and we revise
that regularly and bring that to the
committee side of it and also the budget
setting side where we go through a
process of actually reviewing um our
budgets and looking at that sort of the
gap that we're talking about here and
put forward the measures and the plans
that we could put to uh to reduce that
and that will come forward to
the finance working group and that is
involved in that and then ultimately to
committee um as well so there's activity
taking place around that that is
includes our commercial activity that's
currently happening uh review their
assumptions that we've got existing
budgets and the grant funding
and also the plans to go to the extended
leadership team and look at our teams
and review what we're doing and ideas to
come forward part of that and then go to
the finance working groups and
committees in accordance with that
any more casa stills
there's another one
page 61 r14 unable to recruit and retain
staff with specific skill sets is an at
risk
um
on the at-risk register um what are we
doing to bring that one down
mr holmes thank you chairman
this is an ongoing challenge for us in
terms of as i say recruiting into
specialist roles
there is in particular around planning
there is a national shortage of planners
skill planners um we are in a
competitive environment and local
authorities obviously have to deal with
the private sector and people are
attracted to work as a contractor so
it's a well-recognized um issue um in in
local authorities
as well as this week i was speaking to
the planning advisory service to get
some support from them and we're looking
at a number of options around how we can
actually attract um planners to us how
we can look at changing uh the way we
advertise for planners um how what we
call planners in terms of our structure
and also looking at some other
innovations around offering sort of
experience to uh planners that work at
other authorities um on second who might
come in and do some project work for us
so those things are in train um in terms
of you know we have a number of
vacancies uh that we've been carrying
for uh throughout sort of transformation
through to this period until and and
they've been advertised on numerous
occasions so it is a real struggle um
but there are a number of things that
we're doing now
slightly differently and looking at
things in a slightly different way and
we hope that will actually make a
difference
last one
one more um page 62 r31 which is an
at-risk one which is the resources and
operating staff structure is that
because of
that other risk that that is so high on
the recruiting
essentially yes chilling
thank you thank you cancer said i've got
cancer flu could then cancel chana and
then council of fleming
that's a fluke yeah thank you china i i
just really wanted to drill into
something than this that mr holmes said
because um
if you look at our neighbouring local
authorities chelmsford have 19 vacancies
but none in planning
braintree has 18 and one in building
control colchester 36 interestingly they
have two in building control but they
also have
a vacancy for planning enforcement
apprentice you know i think that needs
looking at doesn't it utterly don't have
any
uh vacancies at all but i suspect that
sanctity of their website tendering 12
vacancies too in beasts in building
control and according to the malden
district council website
um depending how you go into the website
one side says there's only three
vacancies at the council the other side
says there's 13. um but there's only one
in planning and we know that's not right
for the information that
the director of service delivery gave to
members on monday so i'm a slight i miss
really and and members will be aware
uh of an email that i sent this
afternoon that i received from great uh
cambridge who we we work with quite
closely on building projects and you can
see what they say and how they've
managed to recruit quite quickly into
owls you know i know we have a peninsula
effect here but at the end of the day
i was expecting to see a lot of
vacancies locally
and there aren't
so you know i mean pick the intelligence
out of that is that is there a question
there or you just want uh mr holmes to
comment uh councillor fluker
i was just really
questioning
mr holmes in relation to you know what
he says i think that there is a shortage
of planning officers nationally but from
the intelligences that the available
from other councils locally it doesn't
seem to be as bad as what it is for
malden at the moment
so you know i think we and maybe we
should be talking to some of our
neighbours and i know i i think there
was a meeting planned with adam's foot
but um
the um you know this thing about
planning enforcement apprentices you
know and how are these how are our
neighbouring local authorities trying to
you know recruit how they managed to
recoup and i think mr holmes i sent you
the the letter that i received from
greater cambridge and i think it makes
good reading but i'm going to refer to
that later on
mr holmes would you like to come back
and then we'll um go to
council of china thank you i might if i
may just invite um hannah wheatley
especially services manager to um just
give her a comment because obviously um
hannah's role is to as an operational
manager is to fill those vacancies um
and i think hannah might be giving you a
little flavor of sort of some of the
activities we're doing and some of the
challenges we're facing really thank you
hannah would you like to respond
yes thank you
um would you have a number of vacancies
we don't even constantly advertise those
vacancies so there will be a discrepancy
between the number of vacancies that are
carrying and those that are advertised
on our website and also it's important
to stress that sometimes we use the
budget from those vacancies to fund
agency staff where we do have an urgent
need to have someone
supporting the activity within whichever
team we're carrying those vacancies so
sometimes we might need to carry a
vacancy so that we can fund that agency
member of staff and once we're seeing
pressures in the planning team i think
it's important to stress that we do have
similar situations within our other
services to a lesser extent um but we do
go out and we try and advertise those
vacancies and to recruit permanent staff
but as mr holmes has deluded um there
are definitely skill shortages in the
areas that we're looking for and some of
those areas can be quite
specialist areas and i think we're just
seeing a lack of people going into those
certain areas now and it's a certainly a
national problem that we need to
overcome
thank you thank you um councillor chana
uh thank you adam chairman if i go to
page 64 if that's okay and r32
failure to manage the operational impact
of the cost of ring crisis and
obviously it could represent a risk to
services increased demand etc areas of
concern include housing and revenues and
benefits
um i mean mr leslie i'm sure might be
able to expand a bit on this because we
do do quite a bit already actually that
i could see being applied regarding the
cost of living issues in operational
terms
because they would apply to the the
issues there
and you there's several areas which we
do do although it and a lot of it in
collaboration with partners in some form
or other so we've got the do you know
the debt and financial advice statement
um
as i've just rep uh council tax uh the
promote the discounts council tax
support scheme um discretionary hardship
fund financial advice and support um we
give also
and um providing contact housing we do
various things there damage deposit
guarantee rent in advance et cetera and
employment support um
i wonder if you could just expand a bit
on that and because it's a bit of a
perfect storm coming after covid
obviously but what i would ask like to
ask well hanging a hat on it and it was
as a result of something today i picked
up
do we got an awareness because yes uh
we've got our residents being affected
and in fact this council being affected
if you want to want to prepare with cost
of living because inflation if you look
at it
and of course bearing in mind the
financial situation as it is and we know
we've got to keep
an eye on our medium term financial
strategy
are we mindful that perhaps some of our
own workforce
themselves may be subjected to concerns
and issues
um regarding cost of living crisis and
have we got in some intelligence going
to work on that and giving perhaps
necessary support because it's you know
no one is necessarily
not going to be affected by this
regardless actually of cohort
or sector so thank you madam chair
thank you mr leslie
thank you jeff
so in terms of the risk itself what we
were focusing um on on the pressures of
the service that this uh creates we're
looking at potentially uh increase to
the homelessness side of it actually the
budgets around that finding houses
suitable and actually the impact on our
staff as well and also on the rebs and
ben's team which is obviously doing a
lot of good work at the moment in terms
of the tax rebates and all the way
they've done the grants
if that's an increase in terms of the
the housing side of it council tax
support as well and the hardship side of
it so there's a great many potentials
around that um having said there are a
number of things that the council does
uh
to to assist residents uh with this that
that sort of detail is available uh on
the website and uh i believe councillor
channel has covered a lot of those um
things as well and including uh sign
posting uh people to the relevant other
uh partners who can provide that
additional assistance as well as
additional support that may be um
available uh including that sort of the
job seekers side of it uh
and also the the citizens device bureau
which we currently have have with us um
as well so there's a number of
activities uh that we do to help around
that and of course it will have an
impact on our finances which is another
item that was covered um as well which
brings us into the uh budget uh
monitoring process and yes absolutely
that that's covered and we're sort of
seeing that side of it um going on as
well and slightly intimately interlinked
with the workforce side of it one of the
pressures is of course around pay
at the moment that that's uh
looking if we look to that to
factor in in terms of inflation to pay
negotiations we can expect that maybe a
pressure going forward on a national
issue uh for our workforce as well there
of course be costs for example you know
the travel of petrol et cetera as well
as you know even uh home there is the
energy side of it
we do have a well-being uh program in
terms of obviously those are one-to-ones
with members and there's also a number
of well-being activities including
support for um
uh the counselling service
and other activities that take place
within our team as well as those mental
health first aiders that we have
allocated across the council
thank you
the next person please councillor
fleming
thank you chairman um i wanted to return
to page 60 r8 failure to meet the
affordable housing need
it says although risk not changed work
is progressing including utilizing 4.2
million and commuted sums
to bring further forward
to bring forward further affordable
housing i was interested to learn what
what that work was
and um
where the 4.2 sits is it in an earmarked
reserve or
i just would like some more detail thank
you
mr johnson
commuted sums going to it do go into an
earmarked reserve um i can't go to all
of the detail
regarding the work but it has been
shared
with full council um on a couple of
occasions around the commercial projects
that are being brought forward to
deliver um housing projects thank you
thank you um councillor edwards please
but what was your name said about
are
kate
salary limps comparable
mr holmes please
uh thank you chair um
there is an issue around um specialist
pay um when we set our pay grades we we
set various levels for all our
specialists so whether you be a planning
officer reviewing a housing officer
environmental health officer and it
doesn't allow for any sort of market
fluctuation or differential um so often
planners do command a higher salary so
sometimes we have to apply market
supplements just to get
people to apply for role and they should
really only be short periods of time so
we do need to do some benchmarking
around our salaries to see how we're
competing and picking up council lucas
point about or how come others can
recruit in would you say what are you
paying them um i do feel that we will
find a differential and so i believe
that is an issue
and the other thing we we lost uh
through our change is we lost the sort
of career grades that we had was we used
to have a system where someone could
come in as a an
apprentice effectively and come in as a
graduate and could work their way up a
family which we don't have at the moment
so there's a number of things we want to
reintroduce that will potentially look
more attractive to candidates as well
thank you and councillor thompson
councillor edwards beat me to it thank
you chairman and thank you council
records thank you that was almost word
for word thank you brilliant well
members excellent anybody else before we
move on cancer stilts
okay thank you members well the
recommendations uh were as i read out
the members review the corporate risk um
no i'll read them out the members review
the corporate risk register as appendix
one and provide comments and feedback
for consideration little two that
members are assured through this review
that corporate risk and is being managed
effectively little three that members
challenge risk where the committee feels
that the council's corporate goals may
or may not be achieved i can't remember
if i actually proposed it and second did
it that's why i read it again i propose
and it was that you who seconded it
thank you sorry about that members i
didn't make a note of that so is that
agreed by ascent
agreed thank you
you've got to keep your eye on me
counsellor
okay the next one is agenda item 10 um
the purpose of this report is to provide
an update on the covered economic
funding activity from october 2021 uh to
date
we have a small presentation i think
from leander cable is that correct and
hello and welcome
thank you chair and good evening members
i'll share my screen with you to deliver
the presentation
so as part of the local
local authorities code economic recovery
and transformation program
this consisted of the welcome back plant
the contain outbreak management fund
more commonly known as conf and the
additional restrictions grant these
grants were all provided by external
parties mainly central government and
essex county council to support our
communities residents and businesses
through the coming pandemic
the welcome back fund
focused predominantly on visitor areas
and high street
history areas and it was to support the
safe return between the periods of mid
mid 2020 and to the end of march 2022 an
example of the activities which we've
delivered are on the slide now and as
you can see there's a range of
activities to support businesses
residents and the visitor economy the
funding was provided by the european
regional development fund and her
majesty's government and
the department of leveling up
communities and homes
the additional restrictions grant was
provided in several branches
predominantly it was focused on direct
grants to businesses but there was also
elements of business support which could
be delivered under there as well
this focuses on the second tranche which
we received in may 2021
and this is a list of the activities
which we undertook with that
providing in throwing details such as
the uh subsidized membership schemes to
support our businesses to create a more
resilient business community
and then there's also some work we're
doing with the north essex economic
board
that's those authorities in oxford
colchester braintree tendering
chelmsford malden and essex county
council working in partnership to
deliver focused activities around
business support and skills support
the additional restrictions grant whilst
it had to be defrayed on the 31st of
march 2022 the business support activity
can actually continue to the end of this
financial year and those contracts are
being managed to be spent
the contain outbreak management fund
known as the comp fund was
provided to us county council by the
department of social care
who were able to develop programs to
to provide programs to support local
areas obtaining the cognitive outbreak
these came to us in two forms the first
of all was the inflammatories from
public spaces which as they suggest
focused on those open areas
and providing safe access to those areas
during the pathetic and then in the
latter end of last year as the numbers
of overcrowded variant growth the high
street code improvement scheme which we
delivered we delivered a number of
activities to support
the safe events within the town centres
and additional things for public
communities etcetera and fine touch
point areas
that concludes
the report thank you
thank you leander lovely okay members
the recommendation is that the committee
notes the work that has been delivered
as part of the covert economic recovery
and transformation cert
program and the ongoing work to support
our economies um i'd like to propose
that from the chair do i have a
secondary
thank you
members
um councilman fluker thank you chairman
i mean
you know when when the government hands
hands out funding you know the first
thing you do is to say well right we're
going to spend the whole lot so the
first thing i'm absolutely amazed about
that we had an underspend of 115 000
pounds and the other thing chairman is
is and i'm sure the
the the the good folk of
burnham and and morden will be
appreciative for everything that they've
received uh under these schemes but i
don't think southminster got anything
and bearing in mind it's one of the most
depraved areas in in the district i'm
surprised
so
maybe i missed something maybe i was
invited to apply myself maybe i was
supposed to go out and bang on
businesses doors but i mean you know
south minister as far as its high street
is concerned it's always punched above
its weight i mean we currently don't
have any empty shops which is which is
good you know
and we do everything as a parish council
and the work we do with the church to
make sure that you know people are
signposted to local businesses and every
other thing they think but it's
disappointing that i can't see anything
that's gone to southminster
meander cable could you actually ask
answer any questions has anything gone
to south minster do you know
um in terms of direct business grants
and access to the business
support and skills programs i wouldn't
be able to find specific details at this
point but i can certainly review the
details that we have um i did
and the local authorities extensively
publicized the availability um of
the welcome back fund um activity
suggestion form which went out by our
channels and also with regular member
and parish council engagement as well to
bring forward activities that can be
supported under that
chairman and uh
is you know there's something here about
the upgrade of public conveniences and
we've been working for several years
with morgan district council to get ours
upgraded but and they still haven't been
upgraded so you know i'm a slight loss
here and a huge disappointment but i i
look forward to miss gable's response
when she can outline um exactly what
funds have gone to south minster because
i'd be very interested to hear that
chairman and i'm sure you're keen to
move on thank you now it's fine
councillor fluke well well welcome to
have your say more than happy um
counselor channel
i thank you madam chairman um
yes i know i've got it all written in
the report but could uh the officer
please send that presentation around
because i couldn't actually
read it
i know that's there but instead of
waiting for the minutes i think that'd
be quite nice for members to get now uh
now actually because it looked as though
it was really succinct and putting all
the you know real points down and i find
that sort of quite helpful so that could
be circulating madam german it's up to
you because you're the german but ahead
of the minutes i think that might be
helpful to members would you be able to
do that please linda cable send send a
copy of the presentation
and via email to all members um i've got
i can do that
thank you and did anybody else wish to
say anything council stills please
uh yes thank you going on from something
that counselor fluke just said we've got
this
underspend
did we actually have to pay that money
back what did happen to that money that
we haven't spent in these grants
mr leslie
thank you so that that grant obviously
had conditions around the expenditure of
it so if it was not uh spent within that
time it would have to be paid back
okay
members we have a
proposal on the table and second dude
can we agree the recommendation
and i'd like to thank you miss cable
because you've done a lot of hard work
since you've been on this council so
thank you very much
um moving sorry
oh thank you thank you cancer thompson
um gender item 11 chairman
members the purpose of this report
is to update the committee on the
actions identified in the 2021 annual
governance statement um is this miss
hughes again mr dodson ms hughes welcome
back would you like to present the
report for us please
yeah
so this report provides an update on the
actions that were identified in the 2021
annual governance statement
that were based on improving our
governance arrangements
the tabler section 3.5 report shows the
board list that was set out in the
annual governance statement
those in grey at the end of the table
have previously been reported to this
committee as completed
so of the two remaining actions a
commentary is given around progress
and one of them is now highlighted as
complete
and the action of draw out and then all
of our policies and their objectives
through a review of the local
development plan will roll into the
21-22 annual governance action plan as
an ongoing item
the committee around to review the table
and challenge your feedback where
necessary
thank you mr hughes well members the
recommendation is that the committee
reviews the annual governance statements
table updates below and the challenges
were and challenges were necessary i'd
like to propose from the chair do i have
a secondary
council thompson
um
can we agree by a scent no i think
cancer stilts would like to ask a
question
oh and council fleming cancer stilts
please yeah it's just a very quick
question we've got the remote meetings
being complete
but when we had last full council
we back at burnham
that it says here that currently
consideration being given to moving
south eastern area planning committee
back to burnham has that actually been
done
no that has isn't complete as as i
understand it but the the point here was
that
the the remote meeting facilitation at
that time all meetings were here it was
through a um i think it's a motion to
cancel that the the meetings returned
to
to um
burnham
so
that
in the context of what was agreed in the
previous plan
then this was
complete
are you happy with that
okay council fleming please
thank you chair i'm just looking at page
71 has just uh reminded me i'm not sure
whether this could be cheryl um in terms
of reducing our carbon footprint
are are there any plans to do a sort of
baseline audit of our council activities
thank you
oh so mr dodson's coming in this one
would you like me to pick it up um
we are looking at that and we're also um
obviously now appointing the um climate
action officer who's been appointed and
will start so their role is to develop
the the detailed action plan from the
strategy so so those details including
the baseline should come out of that
that action plan
thank you thank you members only
thompson no um stevens
sorry sorry councilman stevens
and it did have the wrong specs on sorry
thank you chair
one question please i can see a lot of
lists of what training courses have
taken place uh during 21 22. i can't see
anything in there about licensing
training um
i took my licensing training in march so
that would have been
[Music]
in that report
there seemed to be some confusion about
my licensing training and whether it was
needed whether it could be funded and
i'm a bit worried really that licensing
training doesn't feature um can someone
reassure me that everyone that needs it
is on the list and will get trained and
has been trained thank you
mrs is that you because that is quite
important thank you yeah
constitutionally we have the
members that sit on licensing
subcommittee to have attended training
and so all members that have been
offered the training and get the
training when they come on board to the
committee and so that's all being
progressed at the moment and obviously
last year because these were the actions
from last year and that was included the
reason that it's not listed
because it's a constitutional
requirement rather than a best practice
point
council steve would you like to come
back on that because i think you shook
your head as though you hadn't been
offered it i would please i and it
whilst it makes total and obvious sense
that licensing training would be
mandatory i wasn't aware of that now i
didn't sit on a licensing committee
because i wasn't invited to them so they
were taking place
but i wasn't invited because i hadn't
been trained
eventually i was invited to training and
immediately took it up and suddenly
became aware of all these licensing
meetings that i could go to so that
isn't really probably how it should work
and i do think that should be looked
into please thank you
did you pick up on that mrs
yeah
and
yeah we'll pick that up with the
licensing committee yeah thank you um
councillor thompson
thank you chairman um yeah i was just
following on from councillor stevens
really because i
don't exactly remember the last time i
had my licensing training but it was
during coverage because it was remote
um
there must be a statutory
ruling presumably statutory requirement
on training and frequency and
and level and at one point if i may what
we really need and i'm not sure what
council stephens had and
certainly she hasn't said
she wasn't happy with it but what we
need
is training as decision makers
not
necessarily understanding the role of a
licensing officer not that that isn't
interesting but it doesn't actually help
us when we're on the
committee because you know if i need to
know something technical i ask the
office and that's why they're there and
you know if i was ever going to be any
good as a licensing officer i would have
done the training and got a job thank
you
i thought it it's good to miss you
sorry
oh sorry sorry just wait with us miss
hughes
yeah so the um
obviously i'll pick this up with the
licensing committee online um
we've recently circulated an email to
the licensing committee members for
clarification around training and the
plan around training for this year and
so we're picking up on that point
brilliant so i think everything's in
hand so points well made and thank you
for raising the members uh councillor
channel and then council fleming
thank you um yes i i
like council stevens raised a question
about licensing training recently
because not
uh long after the statutory annual there
could have been a meeting which i think
did go ahead and i made the point well
we don't know who's sitting on the
licensing committee yet have we got
members trained up and that was covered
off and actually i do have a view um
like planning
is um all members even though okay we
have the 10 on the licensing committee i
know it's probably more pertinent than
you are sitting on the licensing
subcommittee but i actually have a view
that all members should have licensing
training open to them because we have
the matter of substitutes
and therefore should anyone in the
licensing committee you can't you know
if you've got to run a sub
then you need to know the member who you
want to be subbed has been trained as
well so that's um my view um and i i
think i have said that in the past and i
think that should be the case it should
be open to all members that might wish
to um attend up because i think ms hugh
said we pick it up um about training for
those members once they come on board
the committee i think i heard that my
view it should be all members should
have an opportunity for licensing
training
mr johnson do you want to comment on
that the thing is um non-alliance can't
be substituted so
they can't that's my understanding not
on earth can they be substituted no so
that no non-aligned members would be uh
trained
um
so that's quite an interesting point if
we're looking at training all members
because you're excluding
quite a large number of councillors uh
anyway
mr johnson my understanding was that we
had a pool of 10 but they didn't all sit
on each time and that that was why
they were all trained and then each
committee is made up of a selection of
those those 10 um within the pool
was was my understanding of how it
worked i i may be wrong on that um
all members can be offered um
license and training but it's a matter
of resource and and cost
ultimately
um counselor and then
there's the distinction between the
licensing committee and the licensing
subcommittee
and i think we're talking about the
members who even sit on the licensing
committee might need to be trained um
why are you saying that it's only those
that sit on the licensing subcommittee
because i still think you need to have a
an understanding of licensing matters
regarding the both committees this
licensing committee and the subcommittee
it's the subcommittee that sits normally
to
consider the applications
but actually
there is training that covers a whole
host of licensing matters that might
indeed come under the licensing
committee
so am i wrong in that then so what
you're saying is it's only the licensing
subcommittee members have i
misinterpreted what you said i'm saying
it should be the licensing committee but
they don't all sit on the licensing
subcommittee
okay councillor fluker and then
councillor thompson yeah
my understanding of this is is that when
the licensing committee sits it sits as
a statutory committee or council the
same way as the lpa sits so you don't
have
political substitutions you're either
part of the cohort of 10 that mr dobson
refers to and then anybody that's in
that tent can sit on it it's not
politically balanced you know
um
so
and the other thing is i was a bit
surprised what mr dodson said
is fast fact that it costs the same
amount of money to train 30 world
members it does 10 if it's all done on
the same day and you know i've done this
training several times in the past so uh
you know maybe if when we go forward
particularly in the next administration
if there's a lot more people want to be
involved then let them all be trained
let them all join the cohort and let
them all be invited to go and sit on a
um
quasi-judicial
licensing committee i mean it is you
know it it to be honest and i know
councillor thompson thoroughly enjoys it
being chairman and it's always been a
great pleasure supporting her as well
when she's been chairman but it is quite
you know it is it's a very important
thing that you're doing because you've
actually taken over from the magistrates
court and i think it's important for as
many members as possible to be involved
in that
so
i i'm sure mr jennings is listening and
mr dodson's writing it all down
but yeah perhaps we should look at that
i don't like it when members feel
excluded
even when it comes to motions i don't
like it
thank you cancer blue cancer thompson
then council fleming
thank you chairman um
will be surprised to hear i'm with him
on that one um i my belief and i have
been on licensing for as far back as i
can remember is that
the members of the licensing committee
have to be trained to sit on the
subcommittees because that's the quota
judicial part
but you don't need it to sit on a
licensing committee per se which i also
have to say
i can't remember the last time it met to
make a decision because licensing will
only meet
as a committee of itself to make a
decision on licensing policy something
like that and since nearly over is
nearly all of its com encompassed in
legislation anyway that doesn't leave us
a lot of room for maneuver
um but i certainly agree with council
channel and council of fluger that you
know if there is an opportunity for
other people to uh
to attend the training cost issues being
either
zero or
very small and i would say that would be
a good thing but no the substitution
comes from taking the three or four from
ten i mean you only need three to be
quarter so it shouldn't be too difficult
to get the three from the 10.
thank you through youtube just so i can
understand what's going on here and two
questions for councillor stephen so can
i ask how long you've been on the
licensing committee how long it took to
get training and then i have a question
for councillor thompson through you
chair you as chair of the licensing
committee do you pick the subcommittee
thank you
councillor um
stevens i've got a mental still
councillor yes
through your chair thank you um yes i
came onto the licensing committee in may
21 and went on my training in march 22.
thank you
yeah of course
and have you sit on sat on the
subcommittee yet
once since the training but i think
there might have been occasions before
that where i didn't know that it was
even meeting
because i wasn't invited because i
hadn't been trained if i'd known the
meetings were happening i would have
been asking well what training can i go
on because presumably during covid i
could have attended the training of any
council up and down the land because
they must have all been remote so it
should have been easier actually than
normal thank you okay thank you i think
it's points well made um
the proposal has been made and seconded
can we agree by ascent members
yeah of course you can cancel something
yep
i'm actually not
the chairman of licensing and
it says something about how often that
means that i don't know who is
um i think councillor fluke was actually
referring to chairing the subcommittee
which
no they're not chosen by the
support currently anonymous chairman of
licensing and that tends to be dealt
with by committee services because
amongst other things and i don't think
this is statutory but committee services
do try not to allocate
allocators to cases in our own wards
just in case it does happen to be our
local pub convenience store whatever
um
usually anyone who's eligible gets an
email are you available on these dates
please let us know and that's how it
happens
but one one question i would like to ask
and and it will be a statutory or well i
don't know maybe not statutory
now that we have three or three or four
and we must have three but four can sit
if four are available because we used to
send one of the four who turned up home
which is a bit silly um do
all four have to be trained
to sit presumably if you're part of the
decision making you notice all four do
but i would imagine so otherwise anyone
can see anyone can attend a licensing
committee they're a member of the public
just not the decision making yeah yeah
thank you you'd have to be trained okay
thank you members we're going to move on
to agenda item 12 um the draft annual
government statement 2022-23
uh the purpose of the report is to
provide an annual government statement
the ags to review and adoption
and this is miss hughes again
you'd like to present the report and
then i'll read the recommendations thank
you
yeah so the annual governance statement
follows our 2021 template to reflect it
sit for best practice advice
and is provided as an appendix to this
report
it's provided as a separate item to the
statement of accounts to highlight the
importance of governance and our
analysis of the governance arrangements
for the 21-22 financial year
the report comments on malden district
council's position against the seven
principles of good governance which have
been identified by zipper and solid in
2016
and within the appendix page 79 of your
report
we also highlight the achievements of
the 21-22 financial year in terms of our
governance arrangement
overall we perform well against the
criteria for good governance with some
comments on areas of challenge
but we have also identified an action
plan to build on this for 2223
and that's set out on page 81 of your
report pack
the covering report provided recommends
that performance governance and audit
committee approved to draft annual
governance data to be appended to the
statement of accounts and that the
committee agreed to monitor the actions
as set up
thank you so the recommendations
uh to approve the annual government
statement as appendix a and that is the
appended is appended to the statement to
accounts it's totally what misuses said
little too that the performance
governance and audit committee monitor
the progress of the action plan and
little three that a quarterly report of
annual governance actions is provided
for performance governance and audit
committee review i so propose do i have
a second council of fleming members i'll
open it up does anybody have any
questions
or do you want to agree by sent
agreed
thank you members
all right
moving on
gender item 13.
headline results an action plan of the
staff survey the purpose of this report
is to update committee members on the
recent staff survey results and gather
committee feedback on the association
action plan that has been put together
by the management team i think this is
you again cheryl i miss you sorry i
shouldn't have called you cheryl and
would you like to present your paper
miss hughes
yeah so the report provides an update on
the key findings and the action plan for
the annual staff survey
and it ran for the third time from the
17th of november to the 17th of december
2021
the internal document with the full
results for survey have been published
and they are available to staff of
members through the fresh service
internal system
but this gives a high level update
section 3.3 sets out the positive
highlights of the survey and section 3.4
gives the areas of concern for this year
the leadership team held a workshop to
review the details of the stern feedback
and draw together a live action plan
that will be monitored for progress
the headlines of this are set out in
section 3.5 of the government report and
plans also include running a smaller
pulse survey
this july to seeing progress has been
made so far
members are invited to review and
comment on the information set out and
confirm their assurance that our
response to the stem
feedback is being managed effectively
uh thank you mr so
members the recommendations are little
one that the committee review and
comment on the staff survey results and
associated action plan activities listed
in section 3.5 little to that members
confirm through this that they are
assured that staff survey response is
being effectively managed i so propose
do i have a secondary thank you council
fleming members do you have any
questions on this okay councillor
fleming did you put your hand up oh i'm
sorry cats
councillor fluker
yeah thank you chairman i i
was quite interested in this report
because i can remember it feels like a
long time ago now probably about eight
or nine years ago um when the actual
staff survey was actually member-led
through overview and scrutiny
and uh and they did such a good job the
oviatt scrutiny committee
that they actually won a national award
and i remember going along to collect it
with mr white who uh i i saw not long
ago actually um
so
yeah so we've we've done well in the
past but in the past we always used to
make it mandatory to return even though
it was anonymous we used to make it
mandatory so
you know again the response response
rate at 72 i you know what i'd like to
hear is the views of those people that
didn't respond
you know um and also
again you can
you can go through this
and look at the highlights sort of think
about the questions what they might have
been but it would have been really
really good to understand what the
questions were
and and
you know whether or not members you know
wanted to have any input in it because
in the past they did
um and
i can honestly say that if we go back
nine years or whenever it was you know
because of the staff survey and all the
things that happened at that time there
did seem to be
i think it's probably only richard who
could possibly support me on this after
all this time and and uh and can i say
that um
staff promotion reached through the
ranks nobody's ever gone from draftsman
to head of paid service and you should
be commended for that um but yeah i mean
you know i really do think we should go
back and have a look at some of the
outcomes for those surveys in relation
to what we're doing now some of the
questions that were asked because we did
have really really good we used to have
a a member officer staff forum which was
hugely successful you know members used
to come along and and
and be berated by uh officers and and
there was an awful lot of good came out
of it you know particularly about
engagement and planning and that type of
thing i'm not saying that that is now
the right model for today but it i'm
just very very disappointed that only
sort of 70 odd percent
return their surveys
so there's a few i i'll let mr holmes
take all those points away
okay thank you mr holmes
mandatory is difficult obviously we want
we want people to complete the survey
and actually we need to actively
encourage them and be the team meetings
we're having to to encourage the
feedback um but one of the bullet points
you'll see under section 3.5 is actually
to look at these workshops i think that
probably describes what what you
suggested before so we do get together
um with members have those honest
conversations and
planning is a good example where i think
we're all trying to achieve the same
things and i think it'd be really good
to get planning officers and members
together have some some open dialogue so
that's certainly on the list
thank you and
maybe if you're indulging maybe the best
uh maybe the best thing to say is that
everybody that enters the anonymous the
anonymous return goes into a raffle to
get a day off it won't cost us anything
because we don't know who sent it
thank you councillor
i think quite seriously though i think
you know i'm sure um that miss hughes
has taken on these comments and and i
think one of the things we should do is
we should look at that 73 as kpi and
we must try and move that north next
time it's absolutely essential okay
thank you i think cancer channel had her
hand up next uh
thank you madam chairman um i'll go to
3.4 she's on page i can't move my thing
up now but 3.4 it's the negative themes
that stood out
in 2021 survey
and um somewhat
disappointing i think because what they
do perhaps tell us
we see pride in working from walden
district council has gone down
fewer staff agreed that mdc was changing
for the better
for your staff are happy in their job
member culture uh that's one that
interests me and the impact of behaviors
highlighted as a concern
in many comments and 39
and what also worrying is 48 staff
that's very high
who um well 39 and 48 where they have
the excess pressure in workload and then
48 having to work over the contracted
hours to get work done
and i'd like to know i mean they're
talking about that being long term
because there's a difference between
when you do have to have the push on and
do sometimes like we've all done in life
you know make sure you work over over
the hours to get the job done but if
that's continual that can have quite a
damaging offense again it can lose the
family work family life private life
balance
um i i would actually quite like to have
the percentages about the number
uh member culture and the impact of
behaviors highlighted as a concern in
many comments i'd actually perhaps like
the percentages of that i think that
would be quite handy bearing in mind
percentage has been given in the others
the bullet points and also pure staff
agreed that mdc was changing for the
better i think we can have the
percentages there because for that
statement to be made we obviously know
what the figure was before we know what
it is now and i think that would be
quite helpful
and i do like the fact that about the
member and officer workshops to build
understanding and relationships
and i also think the induction process
can help sometimes uh bring forward what
what members are because i think for
staff that don't meet members regularly
then i can see that being quite daunting
possibly or not understanding and also
um
the understanding you know the political
environment uh which which councils are
which is different to other workplaces
especially but 3.4 was the one that drew
a greater interest and i would like
those percentages the two bullet points
that haven't got them applied by the
chairman thank you thank you misuse
would you be able to provide those
percentages
we will look at that
but the uh caveat that i will give is
obviously staff when asked about another
culture and we just asked an open-ended
comment box for staff to give their
feedback so it might be that a
greater percentage felt a certain way
but
the open-ended comments and but we can't
quantify how many staff did make that
comment and that felt that they wanted
to make that comment in the open-ended
comment box so just the caveat i'll give
it that it wasn't a sex question so it
wouldn't be the same as the 39 the 48
could i ask you a question at this stage
isn't the full survey available to
members i'm sure there's a link because
i've had it
fresh serve i think if if members want
it you can actually look at it in its
entirety it has been out for some time
now anyway
okay thank you for that cancer channel
um cancer fleming then councillor
edwards please
thank you chairman um i just want to
carry on from what councillor channel
was saying about the induction
process
my comment
to
show would be that the induction process
is a perfect opportunity for building
good member
officer
relationships i think that i remember
when i first started i think we had
planning training i remembered actually
not really being introduced to many
officers so it wasn't you know it wasn't
uh
cancer fleming this is so and so um only
really if i was at a meeting so most of
the time i had really no idea if they
were in in person who the officers were
um i mean
it's sort of basics like that i think so
and so i i think that
next may should be seen as the perfect
opportunity to start afresh and
build from there because you'll probably
have lots of new members and and things
will be better thank you thank you i
think very well made points um
councillor edwards please
uh i was just
six month pulse survey i'm not sure what
that actually refers to
but
talking about a percentage of staff not
putting these
uh
surveys or returning the surveys or
completing them
do
does the council have a system of
appraisals from their nine managers when
would these i think you come out
mr holland yes
yes
staff do have regular appraisals and
one-to-one meetings um as we said before
we can encourage our staff it's a survey
um we encourage staff to complete the
survey we don't say you must complete
the survey we urge them to um so it's
not a mandatory thing um but i think it
really is for us as managers to actually
talk to our staff and encourage them to
report that good or bad really and i
think that's where we need to
say it's been suggested it comes as kpi
well let's see if we can improve that
figure so i think that's what we'll have
to do
well yes i mean we do do those as a
mandatory thing it's this is a staff
survey about their feelings so it's it's
looked at differently we want them to do
this survey not tell them to do this
survey if you that's part about feedback
as well isn't it so thank you i'm just
going to come back to cancer fleming
thank you i know i agree with that with
councillor fluker i think that uh the
staff survey should become a kpi and we
could incentivize staff to um
return we could offer a day trip to
southminster
that's one of the prizes
it's
lovely it is lovely and you do some good
good events there um so we're going to
move on to councillor stilts then
council no i'm going to leave you last
council stilts i'm going to go to cancer
thompson stevenson and then stilts
please
casa thompson thank you chairman um i
was just wondering i will go away and
read the star survey properly but i was
just wondering if if any staff tend not
to respond because
their answers would give away who they
were in a small department you know
where there's a job only that he's only
a function is only carried out by a
couple of people that
sort of would would that cause a non
limited to be lost and the other thing
is how how do you incentivize an
anonymous
when you don't
well well-made
i don't think anybody needs to comment
on that oh yes mr holmes would like to
come in i need to give that reassurance
i mean this stuff it is done as an
anonymous survey and and yes if people's
comments are
very pointed um potentially yes i don't
know whether
mrs hughes would like to make any
comment around the moderation around
that but um yeah we do what we can to
guarantee that staff can be as free and
open as they would like to be
yes
sorry uh yeah i do understand that and
thank you through you to mr holmes yeah
i just wondered you know
dead giveaways brings to mind sometimes
you can't say anything without reboots i
think in that room
i think councillor thompson is a very
valid point somebody bolts it if they
know they can be identified if it's
negative i think it's a very well point
well made um cancer stevens
thank you chair um a couple of the
things i was going to say have just been
covered but the other one was um
under 3.4 where it refers to member
culture i think
i hope we can imagine what that is about
but if it's wider and if it's relating
to any members who are still
um
who are still members um i think we
should know more about that i don't know
if i'm likely to find that out by
reading the survey and apologies because
i didn't realize it was online and i'll
look for it
but i would like assurance that if
anybody who is still a member
is part of that problem
that that is being addressed to that
member
is that possible to have that
confirmation thank you
um i don't think you
miss hughes would you like to answer
that i don't think i'm going to comment
on that because i i think it's
there's ways and means but can't misuse
it i think we can look at the comments
um but again with it being an anonymous
survey we wouldn't have that drill down
on detail and the comments themselves uh
do highlight like the particular things
that were upset in staff so that might
give a wider idea as well and so
it's best to look at the full survey and
it will give a bit of an idea
then
yeah i don't
that's fine thank you don't need it any
further because what would happen anyway
they have directors the oblige managers
that they could report if there's an
issue with a member of staff anywhere a
member via a member of staff anyway so
there are processes and procedures in
places mr holmes and
the two directors you will deal with
that if there's an issue from members
being disrespectful or whatever to staff
there's there is policies yeah so be
assured that that is actually in place
but a very good question do you have
another question no that's it thank you
very much council stilts please
um miner actually was going on from what
councillor jana said and that was
looking at 3.4 um and looking at the way
that the staff feel about their
working environment and working here
and we know that when staff are not
happy in their working environment that
you'll get more sickness
so how are we addressing
that because you know if we're getting
long-term sick or staff going off sick
that's going to cost the council money
because
they're not doing the job
so that was my question
mr holmes is that one for you i'm sorry
sorry mr dudson do you apologize yeah
our sickness levels actually are quite
low levels at the moment
i think the worry is
that with this information that we've
seen that that might may not be the case
for long
um you know we've clearly got resource
issues when when staff are having to
work um
the the
hours that they are to get the job done
and i think as um i think it was
councillor china said you know that that
happens over short periods where where
there are projects that need to get done
but when that becomes the norm it's
something that we we need to address so
i think that's the key thing
um that we can do i think it is
testament to the support that
managers are giving and some of the
welfare support that we we put in
that we're not seeing the impact of that
yet but we certainly will if we don't
address it over the coming months
thanks very good question um anybody can
go have burnout and if you're not
careful and i think council china refer
to the work-life balance it's important
members have that as well as officers
and team members
um anyway they're the recommendations
and the proposal of secondary can we
agree by assent please okay moving on
agenda item 14 members motion notice of
motion referred by statutory annual
council the purpose of this report is
of the report is to enable the committee
to dis oh sorry my brain's gone to
consider the motion put forward by
councillor fluke at statutory annual
council on the 12th of may 22 which was
referred to performance governance and
audit committee for review
the presentation on planning service
provides an overview and customer
satisfaction performance management and
respect of the issues raised now
councillor fluka you've got five minutes
obviously to speak on this would you
like the presentation to take first
place first council of luca well
chairman i must i must admit i don't
sort of recognize the way the report's
written but
i mean i as far as um paragraph 3.3 is
concerned it says the presentation that
today's committee on planning services
is in response uh to the issues raised
in my emotions so i think that you know
that says quite clearly that mr holmes
has responded to the motion
um and that he's going to bring forward
his report and i think it would be best
if we if we hear that report and then um
and then i'll decide what i'm going to
do within my five minutes when i might
chairman choose that five minutes to
announce to the council that we're now
scoping the new medical center in
southminster i knew you was going to say
that councillor yes i totally agree i
think the report should it's a
presentation should go first but i
wanted to ask you as it was your motion
mr holmes
thank you chairman uh so hopefully with
the wonders of technology uh miss burb
will load the presentation for you um so
i'd first like to explain the reasons
why you're receiving a presentation this
evening rather than a formal report it's
simply a deadline issue in terms of
being available to produce the report in
time for the committee deadline and i
was uh working on another project so it
has to be this way unfortunately um so
i'll be giving the presentation this
evening along with my customer community
casework manager sue green and my
specialist services manager hannah
wheatley who's online so next slide
please tara
set on slide two is is the actual motion
itself and you'll see that it was to
counsellor was referred to uh this
committee for consideration so if we can
go to slide three tara
so i think the first thing to say as
managers we obviously would like to
apologize for the difficult that some of
our customers are facing um contacting
the council or
receiving timely uh responses from us
there are a number of ongoing issues
that the council is dealing with and i
hope to set out in this very short
presentation some of them for members to
uh to understand and obviously give the
opportunity for some questions um we've
sort of focused down onto three areas
the star vacancies and workload
some systems issues we've identified and
something that relates back to the
design of the service that came out of
our 2018 presentation
so i think we'll look at them one by one
i've got a slide on each just to
illustrate some of the background issues
and i'll hand over to hannah wheatley
now to take us through slide
sorry sue am i doing hello sorry sue uh
to hannah wheatley take us through slide
four please
thank you uh mr home so
first of all this slide represents the
number of vacancies that we currently
have within the development management
department so
we've not been able to recruit into some
posts for a very long time um as you'll
see on the table here the red lines
indicate where we have been carrying
vacancies and on the very left hand side
in the column you can see which role it
relates to that i appreciate with the
current
organizational types because it might
not be completely clear miss sweetly can
i can i stop you a minute members are
finding it really difficult to read that
can it be made the screen be made bit
larger or can they have copies of that
later you talk through it and they need
copies because they can hardly read it
have you got it oh so have you are you
okay then members
sorry it's still a bit small it doesn't
matter if you can't make it bigger
that's absolutely fine
okay all right sorry to interrupt you
sweetly that's okay thank you
um i believe the copy was circulated
earlier and um can make sure that
everyone's got a copy of this so that
you can see the level of detail
but hopefully what you will be able to
see from a distance is that as we move
halfway through 2021 there's a lot more
red as we start to see more people leave
and more vacancies being carried through
um i have highlighted in there but we've
also had some maternity leave um what i
haven't highlighted in here is where
we've had agency cover to try and
provide some resilience within that team
but as you can see the number of
vacancies we carry trying to bring in
agency staff that cost two or three
times as much as our permanent resources
do it it's very very challenging
um
mr holmes touched on the fact that
there's been a number of factors that
influence our ability to recruit and
retain staff
because we're carrying so many vacancies
we have limited capacity to train and
develop our staff
and give them that time out the working
day to be able to attend training
courses
we do try our best to
ensure that our offices have training
and development plans
but that time is very much restricted
when they do have to work to tight
deadlines to get reports finished etc
let me move on to the next slide please
tara
so i'll hand over to my colleague screen
for system issues
thank you members um as part of the work
that we did
in 2019 to implement
our current structure there was a huge
investment in rit
the
a lot of that infrastructure set us in a
really good path in terms of being able
to work remotely
so when we went into the pandemic we
were in a really good place to ensure
that we were able to continue to deliver
our services by staff being able to work
remotely
and we've also invested heavily in
online services and our website which
again put us in a great position to be
able to ensure customers had a really
good continuity of service
one of the really key pieces of
infrastructure we put in place was a
customer
relationship management system
this is something we didn't previously
have and was put in place um in 2019 and
the main purpose was to control all of
the incoming correspondence into the
organization
so that we would have a single customer
record and we could then ensure that
customer enquiries were tracked and we
were able to get that clear oversight of
all the customer contacts
that's a really cool principle of of the
model because
as i'll go into a bit more detail
a huge amount of customer self service
or customers coming in via our website
was a really key really key part of our
restructure proposals
in practice what we have found is that
customers
don't necessarily like to use
our online dash system it does require
registration upfront so customers create
an account with us
they do prefer to use email um
and as a result what we have found is
that our customers are contacting in
lots of different ways
so currently they can contact us far
dash
they can contact us via our
other online forms
they can contact us for
historic email so where we've had
generic email accounts customers have
found those old email accounts and they
are still sending emails through to
those
and they have got or have worked out
personal emails of individual staff so
they still send emails directly to staff
and as a consequence we are getting a
lot of correspondence that's coming in
in lots of multiple ways
and therefore it's really difficult to
have a single view of that customer
contact because we'll have
correspondence coming in perhaps on the
same map into lots of different systems
and so it makes it very very challenging
to be able to have that single view of
the customer
it makes it very difficult for us as
managers to be able to track that
correspondence
and to be able to respond in a timely
way and because it could be that some of
the information has gone to one officer
who may not be in that day there could
be copies into other managers there
could be correspondence that's coming
via our email so in order to ensure that
we can give that really good robust
response
we're often having information in
different places so that is is really
impeding our ability to
provide that that really good seamless
service and also our ability to report
because we are having information coming
in lots of different formats
and that that really makes it very
difficult to us to report on performance
and a lot of our information does have
to be collated manually or that
information transferred into other
systems so that we're trying as far as
possible to make sure that information
is there and a good example of that is
our
online applications for grants
those have to be moved out of our
contact system into a documents
management system
and that's a big piece of work it's not
something that can necessarily be fully
automated
but those are some of the sort of system
challenges that are um
behind some of the issues
that we're currently experiencing
we could go on to the next slide that
would be helpful thank you
so we've mentioned that some of the
ways that we work at the moment and some
of the challenges that we're facing
are
very much rooted in some of the changes
that we made to the way that we worked
in in 2019 so i think it would be
helpful to just reflect
on some of those changes that we made
so at the time the future model was very
much based upon transforming the
services um to a very much a digital
online
to the right of that slide you'll see
there's an inverted pyramid and that's a
really good illustration of
one of the really key parts of this
transformation
the top of the
top at the top in tier zero
this is the volume of customers that are
expected to
self-serve
and and have a fully automated service
so that is the biggest proportion of our
customers so this this model was built
on
that assumption that we would be able to
channel shift and get customers to
self-serve
the next teardown is the proportion of
customers that perhaps needed some help
from our customer services advisors
so that is a sort of a smaller
proportion
we then go down into the next tier which
is tier two
so that's our case workers um so they
will be kind of the next point of
contact um and the customers the
intention is that customers will work
their way down those tiers so if a
customer can't serve themselves they
will be served through customer services
if the customer services team can't deal
with it then that would be dealt with by
caseworker and finally tier three which
is our specialists
and the principle there is that very
little of those customers would actually
end up dealing with a specialist
so as you can appreciate
our planning services are predominantly
delivered by our specialist officers and
that's a really good indication of why
our customers aren't dealing directly
with our specialist planning officers
because of the way that that structure
is working
um the resources allocated to the
council in the restructure was on the
premise of that that being delivered
and the savings that we made were
directly attributed to a reduction in
staff
which was linked to that channel shift
and as members may remember we did have
a total reduction of about 30 full-time
equivalent staff as a result of this
restructure which was around about 15 of
our overall staffing levels
whilst there have been some resources
added back since 2019
they are very minimal and have based on
an exception basis
and i think it's fair to say that we are
under resourced
in all of our areas i don't think there
is a single area of the organization
where we feel we are adequately
resourced to provide a level of service
that the customers and members would
expect
and which does not rely on a significant
level of additional work and pressure on
staff and that was reflected very much
in the staff survey where we're seeing
um around 50 percent of our staff are
saying that they are working in that way
under pressure and are not able to do
the what the work that is needed
in the the time that they have
we're also seeing a significant increase
in the level of
low level and also higher level
complaints that are coming through
members
and that's a dissatisfaction with the
levels of service um if i'm really
honest i think the members have been
sorry customers have been
understanding as we've gone through
covid that there's been huge pressures
on the council in terms of delivering
extra services the grants etc but as the
organization's returning back to kind of
a normal level
that tolerance is probably no longer
acceptable by our customers which is why
we're seeing that greater degree i think
of customer dissatisfaction
um we
we do have less specialists in the
council and we are directing our
customers to use those online services
um and we are
trying to minimize that face-to-face
contact because it is a big resource to
manage that level of face-to-face
contact not only is it is an issue in
terms of the amount of resource that's
taking our staff
it's also the cost because the cost of
delivering a face-to-face service
is
100 times more expensive than an online
contact
so it is very expensive for face-to-face
and even telephone contact is about
15 30
between 50 and 30 times more expensive
to manage than online contact so that's
the premise of of the original proposals
that it is a fraction of the cost to
deal with your customers
on an online basis it also has lots of
benefits because that online
service is a very much structured
service so it means if a customer fills
an online form in
we can make sure they complete that and
give us all the information we need so
we aren't having to go back to them so
several times to ask for information
that's missing which you would get in an
unstructured email so there are an awful
lot of benefits but there it also does
provide a number of challenges
and the services that we are able to
deliver under this structure
are perhaps not what members and the
customers would have anticipated and
perhaps
even i think by officers perhaps the
impact and the the impact of that
service delivery i think has really
started to be understood more fully now
um and as i said i think because of the
um the recognition that during covid
there were
i think customers were more accepting of
the levels of service they are the
expectation is that we should be now
moving back to a level of service that
they previously would have had prior to
the restructure
and i think that's where a lot of that
dissatisfaction is is is
is appearing
and that is on top of
the additional pressures that our
planning team are facing at the moment
in terms of the pressures on recruitment
chairman so that was uh
question one i will summarize at the end
for members um and i think before we
just move on to the question two which
is around enforcement i think we've
always got to look at that triangle and
assume the public want to go in at the
tip of that point they want to go
straight to the specialist and it's it
and therefore we've got less specialists
and at the moment they're not designed
to interact to that level and that's
increasingly frustrating for the public
probably yourselves and and um
and our own officers really so i think
that's just trying to set the scene as
to how we're trying and have implemented
the model but some of the
drawbacks we've obviously we've worked
our way through in the last couple of
years but so that was the point one and
point two um goes on to talk about the
enforcement um question um and around
enforcement cases so i'm gonna hand back
to hannah now just to take two slides
and then i'll come to the summary thanks
hello thank you
um so i think it's important to first of
all state that mostly for authorities
and if not all societies have
enforcement backlog um you never clear
all cases completely um but we've known
that we've had a historic background for
some cases which has gradually grown
over the last few years
um central to the issue is the fact that
again as part of the transformation we
saw the enforcement team literally
carved we had two officers that were
left to progress enforcement cases and
unfortunately that just was not
sufficient resource to be able to
proactively
progress
and notice on those enforcement cases we
are in a position now where we're
getting those resources back in place we
have a level two specialist who joined
the enforcement team at the beginning of
april
and we're looking to get an enforceable
caseworker hopefully starting towards
the end of july
once we've got those resources in place
they will be refocusing
um working their way through that
backlog to try and close those cases
that have been open where there's you
know no possible
recourse or action that can be taken um
so hopefully we will start to see that
backlog food and reduce and that
performance will be reported back to
members and i believe those discussions
are already underway in terms of the
mechanisms for providing that that
feedback
um the complaints that they're working
through are largely determined by
member and resident complaints
we do receive a lot of complaints in
relation to enforcement which is
expected given the fact that we've not
been able to fully resource that service
but that focus is very much then spent
on providing updates in relation to
those in complaints rather than focusing
on those enforcement cases in any
logical order so it is important that we
try and give them a bit of breathing
space so that they've got time to come
up with a plan of action
and to make sure that they are working
through those cases in that logical
order
so the next one
the next slide just demonstrates um
where we are with those resources in the
backlog
so hopefully
again i appreciate you might not be able
to see the detail in this chart
um but it gives an indication of the
backlog the number of cases that were
closed from quarter one in 2017 to 18
all the way up to a quarter three in
2019 which is where we went live with
the transformation
and you'll see that there was an almost
immediate drop off of the number of
cases that were being closed
so this quite clearly correlates with
the fact that we lost those resources
um but we are hopeful now that we're
getting those new resources in place
that we will start to see those bars
increasing as they go through the
backlog and start to close those cases
so it is a good news story it is
something that we are um going to be
able to see that improvement in the
coming months it won't happen overnight
so i would say please just bear with us
there with the team um that they are
getting to grips with it and they will
start to close more cases over the
coming months
thank you
thank you if we go on to the last slide
please uh tara and one more
thank you
thank you
so in terms of what are we going to do
about it and obviously we're looking at
some improvement activities um in sort
of a short term and as soon as possible
um and then in the medium term during
this year so perhaps um to talk a little
bit about some of the short-term
activities we certainly want to
prioritize our activity and resources
around development management and
enforcement as you've heard and to do
that we need to focus some of our
existing staff and to actually put their
attention to those areas of our work and
set up some action plans around those so
that we can actually monitor progress on
that and so we are having the
discussions and with the staff and how
we're going to reorganize ourselves to
do that and also looking for support
from our our colleagues in planning
policy who have some capacity to help us
around that
mentioned around our recruitment options
we need to do something different and as
we've said we've already reached out to
people such as planning advisory service
the local government association has
some really positive meetings with them
and obviously i'll be taking on board
some of the information that's been
provided me today in terms of how others
have worked to achieve some improvement
in in our recruitment options
um
clearly we've identified a systems
problem in terms of how we view and see
the work coming through to the council
and i can't underestimate how many
emails we receive on a daily basis all
of us and if you multiply that by kind
of website inquiries
fresh service tickets you know it's a
constant and obviously it happens and
people do miss correspondence it's not a
concern around how we deal with our
planning apps because we have a uniform
system so the major information is is
there it's all the peripheral stuff that
comes with it that we're not able to uh
tie back down again and make sure we've
got to focus on making sure customers
are responding to in a timely manner so
we again we're looking at our um
business analysts are going to help us
with that we're also doing some work
with um
another couple of local authorities on a
larger project about how we can improve
our um
call handling and message handling so
there's there's an activity working on
that right now
and i think that the final thing in the
sort of short term is we've we've been
working for some time on um a set of
data um and dashboard for all of our
services and it's just coming to
fruition now probably in the next couple
of weeks the the information will start
to go live so i'm very confident we'll
be able to give you a little bit more
detail than perhaps you see in in the
quarterly reports
and we can discuss with members about
the level of detail they'd like to see
and that will again help us and track
hopefully that improvement
so we'll be getting on with that now
but in the medium term then obviously we
do feel we want to have a look at the
structure and how those services are put
together and to aid some of our
recruitment and retention and obviously
how we we do access the public um you
know we we have set out to deliver
channel shift and we have delivered that
the question is is that exactly what we
want to do now so i think we do need to
look some options around that for
members to consider themselves
the way we are structured the ignite
model
and the splitting of our functional and
operational
is an issue in terms of planning
officers and professional staff
it sometimes doesn't look as obvious to
those
applicants how we are set up and
structured and because we split away
operational and functional management of
staff for instance as well as being a
planner some staff we lost one or two
staff because they didn't want to work
in that environment we have others that
have not applied because they wanted to
have staff management experience so
there's something in there that we need
to say um is are we portraying ourselves
in the right way do we need to reshape
ourselves slightly to improve our our
chances of improving um our recruitment
into into the team
um so i think that's the summary um of
of the questions and we've had to
explain the background so you can
understand um perhaps the broader issues
we're dealing with that might help you
with the answers we've given thank you
jim um brilliant thank you mr holmes um
and um officers i think that was an
excellent presentation explained um
quite full very fully actually um
council fluke would you like to um speak
for your five minutes and then obviously
come back when confirmed it to the to
the chairman what i'd like to do is i
just wanted to ask a couple of questions
for clarity at this stage and and
the first one um
is is to mrs green and this is to do
with dash and self-service now
every other council i deal with on on
planning matters we use the bash system
and if you don't use the dash system and
if you try and go to johnny in the
planning department because you you know
his email address you get told to use
the dash system everybody uses dash um
one little issue i do have is when you
get people saying well my planning
application has not been validated this
hasn't happened and everything else and
then they go on the dash system to ask
the question
and they don't get an answer so that
i appreciate that from what miss green
said
a lot of the time he's been taken up by
people
sort of backdooring
but you know if we're going to channel
shift
and digitize
then we have to take our customers with
us now the starting point of all of
these customers is when they play
digitally online when they put their
planning application and filled in their
application online so we know they're
not adverse to doing it but we also know
that
planning agents and applicants they love
to talk to planning officers
but that's not what this is all about
anymore we can't basically afford that
service anymore and people do have the
channel shift into it so
i hope i mean mr holmes said that you're
going to improve the dashboard or the
dash service and that being the case i
think without fail we should signpost to
all of our customers to dashboard and
and members maybe members maybe rather
than e-mailing officers maybe they
should be encouraged to use fresh
service i mean you look you can shout me
down there i'm sure there's a button on
fresh service that says planning
well help me out
no there's not well do you know what
there should be or there should be a way
because you know miss green you're
trying to bring it all together and if
you can if you can if you can get
i was going to say all the nutty members
some of the members if you bring them
all together
and because there are vociferous
complainants and i i'm one because
people come to me all the time
and they're all upset about things not
being validated this not happening that
not being done documents not up on the
uh thing but it if we could just if we
could just have direct members to fresh
service so then you've got a record
coming through i think i'm right
and and if we can improve dash and make
sure that's properly signposted to
applicants then it's going to make
members life a lot easier
and and then if if members of public
don't get a response through dash then
that's a whole new ball game because
we're actually being told tonight that
that is the way to go and they will get
a response and i think probably the
other thing that needs to be looked at
this this
the response times that sit within our
rules somewhere that say says basically
i think uh
a
telephone call or a
written letter is dealt with in three
days and an email within five days that
in this day and age that doesn't quite
feel right but we need to go
to dash and we need to make sure that
all of our customers go there and we
take all the traffic out the system
because i i think miss jones that's what
the issue is and and just for clarity
and you never said it
um
you i presume you uh you you are going
to report back to council
uh with regards to these these issues
and it's that you seem to have covered
an awful lot over and above what's in
the motions i mean it's communications
with customers if we signpost to dash
that solves the problem and planning
enforcement what i will say is i agree
with you sweetly about what she says
about
all
planning authorities have outstanding
enforcement cases well of course they
would do but i haven't found a plan in
equality locally
that has enforcement cases outstanding
for more than two and a half years
we have them outstanding for seven and
eight years and that's what needs to be
addressed so i mean
i think that we've got to direct our
customers to dash if that's where we
want them to be and yeah
can i talk to you are you are you now
going to do five minutes or do you think
that actually do you think that leads in
no i think
to see where we need to go with this i
totally take on board what you're saying
i'll agree with you
please let me speak okay i take on board
what you're saying but i'm not going to
allow you to have four minutes and then
another five minutes so either well no
say what you want to say well i'll say
what i want to say now and then you know
i think mr holmes has if he hasn't
agreed for the benefit of the tape i
think he's definitely acquiesced to say
that he is going to report back to
council with regards to communications
and outstanding cases i think that's
that will be correct that is a given so
um
what i would like to say that
my motion was was in the spirit that it
was meant and and nobody needs to tell
me and and i would like to remind all
members that that whilst members have a
right to challenge
um
on service level service level outputs
members are not responsibility
not responsible for designing processes
that's not what we're here for that's
operational
it's also worth noting when you look at
those those screens
the
the recruitment position or the
establishment position is no different
now than what it was a year ago so i do
wonder why we didn't bring this forward
a year ago and say look you know we've
got a problem here we can't solve it
what are we going to do
and as far as auctioneering is concerned
and i'm surprised
that
both this report and the private and
confidential report that members had
sight of on monday
um never touched on the schema
delegation
we know how much work that generates the
way the schema delegation is at the
moment
a review of planning committees again we
know how much work that generates member
call-in
total outsourcing if we can't recruit
then we're going to have to totally
look at total outsourcing you know it's
as simple as that
and the other issue is is the retention
of building control because so many
councils now don't provide building
control uh most large developers now do
their own
um and i think each of those needs to be
properly considered and reported on as
as part of the plan and the strategy the
impact of using policy team members is
port dm
i mean the i mean i'm sure everybody's
realized the impact of what that will
have i mean if we move policy team
members as the suggestion was
over into dm then that means the local
development plan work stalls
and that that we need to be fully aware
of that and also the local development
plan i believe some of the people
involved in that on fixed term contracts
on the understanding and get the work
done so there's a big impact there that
members need to be aware of
and the plan as tabled relies on
recruitment for delivery but it's the
lack of recruitment that's left the lpa
in this predicament so
again
i think the director needs to
demonstrate how he really is going to
close this recruitment problem it's it's
comforting to think that
our neighboring authorities don't have
the vacancies
and and finally to allow for the council
to properly track the role out of the
plan or strategy and objectively
i think what we need is we need an
objectively led timeline
with a parallel cost matrix because
there when we look at this i know we've
got savings because we don't have people
in post but we also
sweetly said that we're also playing
employing consultants at four times the
price so for the eight vacancies you can
only have two consultants so there is
going to be a cost on this you know how
keen i am about budgets
and we need to be fully aware of that so
i hope
i i hope that when you report back to
council mr holmes that you're you'll
cover off the costs the matrix and those
particular things and all of that said
german within the the the graciously
allowed i think probably nine minutes um
if that being the case then chairman i
will withdraw the motion
thank you
uh thank you councillor fluke would you
do we have a second if a councillor fuku
withdrawing the motion what
no he doesn't always being facetious
uh mr holmes would you like to say
anything in response you don't need to
because i think council of lucas was
eloquent
but
he's using evidence against you later on
please silence is golden um
no i appreciate the comments that have
been fed back um by council look at this
evening absolutely we will look at a
number of those um items um just a
couple of points why not a year ago a
year ago we were coming out pandemic
year ago we weren't operating the same
way as we are today because things have
recovered and i think i i've got to say
the staff have given it 110 in trying to
make this work um and i've got nothing
but praise for the efforts that people
have put in but i think you we reach
points actually we need to we need to
have a look at this again and see
potentially to make some some some
changes to where we the way we're
working so take on board all those
things that have been said this evening
and when we when we come back to council
we'll have that detail
thank you
put your microphone on please
i'm sure everybody in this room echo is
what you just said mr thames because we
everybody knows the enormous pressure
the planning apartment's been working
under and and some of that pressure i
really do believe that based on
the comments that have been well
received tonight from me that a lot of
that pressure is going to go away if
members and members of the public both
channel shift and digitize
thank you and i'd like to thank
councillor fluke for drawing that motion
and we're going to move on no i don't
think anything else needs to be said
members so moving on to a gender item
15. um this is quite straightforward
appointment to
of representatives on outside bodies
purpose of the i've got to read it first
council of luca the purpose of this
report is to remind members of the
existing representatives on the outside
bodies and the new appointments to be
made at the municipal year may 2023 the
recommendation is that the committee
appoints representatives to the body's
detail below for the insurance and mr
pulley may 2023
i so propose do i have a seconder
does everybody agree
thank you members
um so members thank you for your
contributions this evening i now draw
the the meeting to a close at 10 pm
exactly
what was the current representative
i was getting too excited then so sorry
members i thought it was just for noting
um well
yes so members are asked to nominate
representatives to serve on the
following outside bodies aligned to the
performance governance and audit
committee for the municipal year we've
got the modern citizens advice bureau
advice bureau liaison committee the
current representatives was councillor
keys council fleming and councillor
stevens can i have your nominations and
does everybody want to
councillor edwards
sorry
can somebody help me uh uh misuse is
still there was councillor edwards
nominated for citizens advice bureau
statutory annual can you
appointment is an recall of the
performance governance committee
thank you miss hughes so can we do do
members please can we do what council
fluke has said and our members agree to
to sit back on that committee
are you it's down to your members okay
the modern district museum liaison
committee council steve's and council
stilts yes
agreed
thank you
all right
yeah it does make sense and finally
members and then i can close the meeting
parish clark's forum chairman of pg a
which is me and substitute is you is
that all right good um agreed now thank
you tara can i close the meeting at 1002